the movie The Matrix everyone thinks
science fiction I go no no that's a
documentary everybody got programmed
that's a fact that's a biological
reality but what was interesting they
always said well there's a red pill and
you could take the red pill you get out
of the program and I go guess what
almost everybody in our audience is
taking that red pill at one time changed
their life it turns out science has
recognized that when you fall in love
you stop playing the programs and you
start creating from your conscious mind
wishes and desires are conscious mind
and so once you let go of the program
and you start creating wishes and
desires it's called the honeymoon
created this heaven on Earth experience
and I go you could have that every day
for every day of your whole life yes we
created that and if you understand you
created then you can say well why didn't
I create it tomorrow and I go you can
create it every day that's the beautiful
part hey seven Carmichael and I make
these videos because running the
business is hard and waking up every day
and getting to work when you're all by
yourself is hard and the thing that
saved me that continues to inspire me
motivate me give me hope inspiration
ideas is looking at the stories of
people who've done a lot more than me
and I learned strategies I get
motivation and it gets me to believe in
myself to go off and attack the day and
so I hope this video inspires you to do
the same as well so today let's get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only Bruce Lipton enjoy
95 of our behavior is coming from sub
below Consciousness and we're the ones
that can't see it when we play it but
everybody else of course is uh seeing
exactly what we're doing so the whole
idea is are you living the life you want
or are you living a life you've been
programmed and answered unfortunately is
most of us are living a life we've been
programmed and and the programming comes
from other people so it's not our lives
the reason let's give a reason why
programming occurs okay the brain is a
computer most powerful computer that
humans have ever experienced but it has
parallels to computers and number one is
this
um in the old days when you would buy a
computer before they put the programs in
you could bring it home brand new
computer plug it in push start boots up
screens on and I say do something and
people well no I can't do anything so
you got a brand new computer you know
first you have to put programs into a
computer before you can use that
computer the brain of a of a human is
the same same thing the screen lights up
in the last trimester of pregnancy it's
ready but there are no programs so the
first seven years of a child's life is
the brain is not operating at the higher
level of Consciousness higher level
higher vibration now that's what we talk
about we put wires on a person's head
electroencephalograph read brain
function a child up through seven is not
operating uh Consciousness except for a
little bit it's primarily operating at a
lower vibration called Theta and I said
well what does Theta I say it's
expressed as imagination so that's how
children can have a tea party and they
pour nothing into the cup and then they
drink the nothing and then they explain
how that was the best tea they ever had
or a child rides a broom saying it's a
horse in the child's mind that is not a
broom it's a it's a horse but it's
mixing imagination and reality but Theta
is hypnosis and the significance of that
is children have to learn how to become
a member of family the rules member of a
community the rules I go how can an
infant a young kid learn these rules
they can't go to school they can't read
the book and all that and I say you
don't have to Nature provided Theta
hypnosis so that they can observe the
parents the family and the community
just observe their behavior and download
those as programs age seven then that's
when they start to become more conscious
and engaging themselves first seven
years is programming but after age seven
95 percent of your life is coming from
that program so if you can program the
child for the first seven years and the
rest of the life of that child is
actually an expression of that program I
was given an opportunity to go to San
Francisco
and have a big presentation at a big
conference on energy and crystals and
stuff like that and I thought well
there's going to be an audience their
energy and Crystal's like okay this
everything I'm talking about in biology
I was so excited and I thought this is
my great opportunity and it was like
like three months before and I thought
okay I'm going to work on this
and then I just let it go I let it go
and now we're getting to a month before
and I said I gotta work on my what's my
seminar going to be what's my seminar
and all I had in my head was okay this
was a new agey kind of thing so I
thought well back then what the heck was
New Age I said oh that's where they wear
all white white shirts and white pants
and a white vest white clothes you know
and that they're so delicate and they
speak in a very quiet tone and they're
so new agey and that really wasn't me I
was like the bull in a china shop you
know it's like hey and it goes no no I
gotta calm down I gotta be cool I'm
gonna present this in a new age fashion
so I tried to formulate a new age me to
present this
well now it's about a week before this
conference it's like my new age me has
not come up with any idea of how to
present this and then it started to get
closer it was just a few days away I'm
gonna go to San Francisco I was like oh
my God I don't have a talk and I just
said forget it let me just be me I just
want to talk the way I want to talk I'm
not going to conform to be some new age
Guru that's not me I'm a science guy and
I'm gonna say what I want to say and
finally in that moment it was just a
couple of days before and all of a
sudden I said that's it no more new age
let's let's write this
and the moment I let go of some Persona
I was supposed to be and just said now
I'm just going to be me all of a sudden
the words started coming out I can
remember I grabbed a yellow pad and I
had a pen and the words started coming
so fast as soon as I said stop being New
Age guys start being Bruce
the words start coming page after page I
was right I had like four or five pages
of notes notes notes notes like after
all those months it was sort of like
okay it was a little constipated in my
Consciousness you know but it all of a
sudden freed up and it's why
I am not them I'm me
and try to act like somebody else
took away everything I was
and that was at the point that said oh
my God
I'm gonna have I'm not gonna alter who I
am I Love This research I'm not going to
tailor it for for that audience and it
was so wonderful because there were
three months where it was just blogging
back in my head back in my head yeah I
gotta do this I didn't do this like
didn't want to do it why because at some
level the first thing was I'm going to
be somebody else I'm going to be Mr New
Age guy
the moment I let go of being somebody
else who became me
then all the words came down your life
95 is coming from the program
your life is a printout of your programs
you just look at your life and recognize
simple fact the things that you like
that come into your life they come in
because you have a program to
acknowledge those things but
the things you wish desire want in your
life and you work hard to make them
happen you struggle you sweat over it
I'm putting a lot of effort in I'm gonna
make this happen why are you working so
hard and the answer is whatever that
destination is your program doesn't
support it and you're trying to use your
conscious creative mind to override the
program I said yeah but conscious Minds
five percent programs 95 percent I go
it's not gonna work very well at all so
that's why poor people stay poor and
rich people stay Rich yep that's why the
book Rich Dad Poor Dad that was exactly
what the whole point was if you grow up
with the programming of a rich family
you don't have to think programming is
subconscious your thinking might be
quite stupid I mean a former president
of ours was a relatively rich person but
not very smart in his conscious mind but
his program was how do I got how I got
rich by what he downloaded that from his
family okay and if you're in a poor
family what did you download oh Life's a
struggle it's not I can't get there as
you know you can change it I say yeah
how can you change this remember I said
well there are two minds conscious is
creative wishes and desires subconscious
hard drive with a program I say the
conscious mind being creative can learn
from anything read a self-help book oh
yeah I know how to do that I said you
read the book I give you a quiz you get
a hundred and it says yeah you know this
stuff and then I say well now that you
know this stuff that your life changed
and the answer is no no
I go why the conscious mind learned from
reading a book that's not how the
subconscious mind learns so our smarts
stay up here I read the book I knew the
information I understood how it worked
blah blah blah blah blah I go yeah
that's the thinking mind that knows but
I go does that translate into
subconscious it's like no it doesn't
because that's not how the subconscious
mind learns you want to change the
subconscious then you have to put in the
data the way the subconscious mind
learns conscious mind creative can learn
from anything you could just go aha I
just changed my mind I can do that okay
subconscious mind habit point of habit
it resists change if a habit changes and
by definition it's not happen anymore so
habits resist change and yet we have
these habits and we want to change them
I said how can I do and I say the only
way you can change the habits is the way
that the habits were learned in the
first place I go what was that I said
first seven years your brain was at a
lower vibration than Consciousness it
was called Theta Theta is hypnosis and I
go oh so what do I do I say well you you
can't just say Okay I want to go into
hypnosis hypnosis is part of a scale of
low vibration going high during the day
and then when you come home from work
the high vibration slows down and goes
to sleep at the lowest vibration so you
go through a range of different
vibrations as you're sleeping Awakening
calm conscious focused conscious you're
at work Focus conscious and I go then
what you come home you calm down now
it's calm conscious and then I say what
then you fall asleep
I said the instant you fall asleep the
next vibration down is Theta I go that's
hypnosis I go yeah so I say then every
night
the moment you fall asleep the brain for
a short period of time is in hypnosis
Theta so I say so what well you're
putting on earphones or ear plugs and
you go to bed playing a program that you
want to be true in your life I say so
what I say you put it on just before you
fall asleep and while you're still awake
you probably hear some of the program
okay but the moment you fall asleep
conscious Minds disconnect it doesn't
hear anything coming off of the program
anymore I said but what does I say ah
the subconscious mind is in Theta record
so whatever's coming through the
earphones is not going into conscious
mind but it's now being directly
downloaded into the subconscious so this
is called self-hypnosis you have to
repeat this process because the amount
of time in Theta is relatively short
before before you hit the lowest
vibration Delta which is sleep outright
okay so every night when you go to bed
just after your Consciousness falls
asleep there's a period of record
opportunity and then we put the
earphones on play the program is called
self-hypnosis that's hypnosis you're
doing it yourself okay number two you
still learn programs after age seven you
learn how to drive a car you learn how
to play an instrument I go well how'd
you do it that way I go repetition
habituation is practicing something and
repeating it and repeating it so many
times that the subconscious finally says
okay I got a pattern I got the pattern
and that pattern then becomes the habit
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there negative thinking is equally
powerful but works in the opposite
direction meaning with positive thinking
you could heal yourself many disease
with negative thinking you can die and
create any disease you can create your
own death just because you believe
you're going to die and all of a sudden
I say well then it's the power believe
positive or negative that is shaping the
world and I go well this is why when we
look at people's beliefs and and they
they do a you know an assessment of they
find out over 60 percent of the beliefs
that we're manifesting every day are
negative and disempowering
self-sabotaging thoughts that we've
acquired such as I'm a victim of my
genes that's a belief and somebody says
yeah well I'm going to die of cancer
because it's running in my in my family
and they get cancer and then they find
out
there's no Gene that causes cancer oh
I'm saying this on uh on Lynn show I
will have to emphasize that there is not
one gene that if you have this Gene you
have cancer genes are correlated with
cancer genes are not causing cancer this
is why half the women that have the
breast cancer Gene brca2 half the women
never got the cancer but they all
possess a gene so where's the point that
said the gene didn't cause it it was a
lifestyle that was not in harmony that
ultimately activated what is called a
cancer Gene I said so what do you mean
so if you change your thoughts and get
rid of cancer I go yeah well that's what
spontaneous remission is all about uh
and so I'm stepping on linsfield here
because this is where this emanation of
thought
and we don't see it and we don't in our
history oh that's just thoughts and
feelings I go those are the controls
that are manifesting your life your
thoughts and your feelings your feelings
are the translation of the energy into
sensation so your feelings are like a
compass they're telling you whether
you're going toward more life or to less
life Consciousness is creating your
reality if you put a picture of fear
into your reality then your biology
Behavior will manifest things to be
afraid of because this is a short
statement but to me it's the most
powerful one simple and short and it
goes like this the function of the mind
is to create coherence between your
beliefs and your reality if I have a
negative belief the function of my mind
is to manifest Behavior to experience
those negative realities if I have
positive beliefs then the function of my
mind is to manifest a positive
experience but we got programmed with so
many negative beliefs and that takes
away our power because we're not
focusing on the beautiful things we're
focusing on the fear what are you afraid
of it is simply impossible to achieve
long-term health and happiness if you
hate yourself
100 this is so important because this is
that was I have a memory of a point in
my life where that change just like boom
just like somebody turned the switch
because I I was on the edge of I could
have been diagnosed as manic depressive
well happy most of the time but once it
started going wrong then it was like
this is wrong and then I give myself the
abuse verbally oh nuts you're stupid
you're not good enough what's wrong with
you Lipton and I'd be doing that and I I
was in my lab and I I just spent a
procedure that took about an hour to
prepare for the experiment and and if
you mess it up just a little bit you
have to start all over again the third
time that day I messed it all up and now
I'm really upset I spent the whole damn
day doing this it didn't work and then
I'm getting oh you Eddie you can't do
anything right and I was giving myself
like a parent on my shoulder telling me
where you're that's not good enough and
I'll never forget there I was alone in a
lab and I hear this voice
there's already there I hear this voice
like you know and the voice says things
don't you have anything better to do
than to listen to this crap
I looked around I started to laugh
because I said sure I'd rather go to a
movie so there was a newspaper I picked
up the paper I found a movie went off to
the theater guess what that whole
dialogue ended instantly I had a choice
I had that's what I was saying I have a
choice do you want to continue this
conversation you want to do something
else
that was the moment of empowerment that
was so great because it said stop
stop do something else get out of here
and and the next time I started to get a
little depressed first thing that came
back was the humor of that and I'd laugh
and I go okay I'll do something else
after three or four times guess what
I've never been depressed since that
time never why
it just doesn't hold in my mind if a
depression you know like a negative
thing starts happening I don't sit there
and play it over and over and over again
which makes you go downhill downhill I
just oh I don't I have a choice it's the
choice do I want to listen to this stuff
or do I want to do something else
everyone thinks diseases related to
genes and I'll tell you what less than
one percent of disease that's connected
to genes that up to 90 percent of
illness is stress related and I go well
what's the consequence I'll tie it into
the corporate thing in a second because
the first two uh consequences of putting
stress hormones in your body are let's
go back a few hundred thousand years
when the only stress was the Sabertooth
tiger chasing you so stress is based on
your ability to escape and your ability
to escape is to use your arms and legs
and I said well you know you want all
the energy in your arms and legs because
you know you don't have to worry about
the gallbladder right now that's not
relevant to cyber and Sabertooth Tiger's
coming so there are three things that I
want to bring up so very number one the
first the first two are physical okay
number one is stress hormones cause the
blood vessels in the gut this area to
shut down in fact when you first feel
fear there's like a butterflies in the
stomach queasy feeling that's actually
the blood vessel squeezing shut and I
say why should the blood vessels squeeze
shut it's like you don't need to
maintain the body if you're trying to
escape the tiger so by squeezing the
blood vessel shut you send the blood to
the arms and legs more more energy
and most important part especially in
today's world is that stress hormones
shut down the immune system that's a
function
it's so effective that when a doctor
wants a transplant an organ into a
foreign person and they don't want the
recipient's immune system to reject it
they give the patient stress hormones
before the transplant because stress
hormones shut down the immune system
reason is simple if you've ever been
sick sometimes you don't even have the
energy to get out of bed and I go well
you know if you have a bacterial
infection and a saber-toothed tiger
chasing you you know it's like well who
cares about the damn bacteria because if
the tiger catches you the bacteria is
not really a problem anymore and so the
immune system is shut down which opens
us up to a problem and in today's
stressed out world the uh the amount of
illness on this planet with all the
money we put into Health Care is rising
all of the time and I go it's because of
the stresses that we're dealing with
that's causing this there are three ways
to change belief okay
self-hypnosis earphones on at night
repetition create a new habit
and third one energy psychology which
allows you to rewrite an existing
program in minutes uh and we need to do
this why
because if you haven't noticed and you
haven't looked out the window the
world's falling apart I go and why is it
falling apart and the answer is because
we're facing what is called the sixth
mass extinction of Life the web of life
is collapsing I go then why is the web
of Life collapsing the answer is human
behavior
I go oh
we don't want the web to collapse
we have to change the behavior
and this is what the world is
experiencing at this time the chaos all
over the world is bringing to light the
fact that these behaviors were
fighting and violently with are
behaviors that have taken us out of
heaven
and put our Consciousness into a world
that we're experiencing which is falling
apart
you want to make a world of heaven then
you change the program and then you
could have Heaven it's your belief
system that creates this you fell in
love because you stopped playing your
program and you created heaven
I say well guess what heaven was always
there except the damn program got in the
way so you want heaven on Earth
don't play the program stay mindful or
be rewrite the existing program and put
heaven on Earth programs in there and
then 95 of the day you'll be playing
that 95 of your life is coming from
observing the other people
not observing you but observing the
other people and so your behavior isn't
yours now Steve brings up the most
important question well how do we change
these behaviors I go first of all you
don't even know what the behaviors are
because you weren't there when they were
being programmed you I don't know what
my behaviors are what what did you learn
when you were in utero oh you don't know
oh okay what did you learn during the
year from zero to one oh oh you weren't
there you don't remember oh what did you
learn from one to two and I'm saying
your conscious mind wasn't working at
that time so whatever happened it's not
in your conscious mind and so the
significance about all this is profound
because what the significance is
then you don't know your program you
don't know your program and I go oh so
what are my programs and now thank God I
can tell you what your programs are
because of this
95 of your life is coming from the
program your life is a printout of your
programs you don't have to go backwards
in your life you could just say Where am
I today and here's a simple point so all
of you out there ready
the things that you like that come into
your life they come in because you have
programs to acknowledge them but
the things you want the things you
desire and you have to work hard you
have to sweat I'm going to make it over
I'm going to sweat over this I can put a
lot I'm putting a lot of effort I'm
working real hard to make this
why are you working so hard
the answer is whatever that destination
you were trying to get to your
subconscious program does not support
that destination and that's why your
conscious mind is working so hard to get
there so I say you got programs and you
got them before you even knew you were
being programmed and then we have to
identify those programs because if you
want to change your life
and you want to make it one that has
wishes
then you have to assess where your
program is now so that you can then
change those programs and create the
life you want there's an old old phrase
number that is just a stock phrase of
the world because it's true is and it
says knowledge is power and everyone
goes oh yeah knowledge and I go no no
let me say in a way that might be
relevant to us now I say a lack of
knowledge is a lack of power
and I say we have been deprived of
knowledge of who we really are how
powerful we are because all the
knowledge we get in growing up is how
weak we are how vulnerable oh my God
viruses are coming parasites are coming
blah blah blah blah blah blah
everything's gonna fall in a bar and I
go
well that's not true
it is true if you don't recognize your
power and I say well what power and I go
well one of the first things that this
empowered us was the belief that genes
control our life oh why is that just
some power us I go well simple point
it says that as far as you know you
didn't pick the genes you came with
if you don't like your characteristics
you can't change the change you came
with and then I add this little last one
the creepy one that says well the genes
turn on and off by themselves Without
You
relevant well if the genes are
controlling my life and they turn it on
they're turning on and off without me I
am definition a victim of my heredity oh
there's heart disease running in my
family oh I'm gonna get it cancer oh I'm
going to get a cancer it's him running
in my jeans I go
that's a bunch of BS oh that means
belief system
why is that relevant I say because the
idea that genes turned on and off by
themselves is the biggest false story
that you bought into which took away
your power because it says Change
Control you you don't control your genes
and that's why you look at your fate is
what James did my mom and dad give me
because my future is going to be
determined and I go
completely false
genes cannot turn on and off and I go
we've been programmed and turned on
cancer Gene turned on gave me cancer I
go no
a gene is a blueprint to make a protein
this and I go okay let's unpack that I
go the body that you see in the mirror
look on the screen see yourself all out
and I go that is made out of protein
building blocks they're about a hundred
thousand different protein types that
come together assemble them together and
I make a muscle cell out of some
proteins make a brain cell out of some
other different proteins so if I you
know try to tell the audience I say well
proteins are like Lego kit Lego Parts
they got a hundred thousand different
pieces different shaped pieces and I say
how you assemble the Lego can create a
muscle cell or how you assemble them can
create a brain cell a skin cell and I go
so the point about it is this proteins
are the building blocks but proteins
break down so you have to replace them
but I go oh they're very complex
molecules I go
where do we get the car the proteins
when they break down I go we have DNA I
say what's that it's a blueprint on how
to make a protein I go so what I go it's
a blueprint and a song I go
this is the story I always say so you go
into an architect's office and she's
working on a blueprint and I say lean
over her shoulder and go hey tell me is
your blueprint on or off
and she was looking to go what are you
crazy it's a blueprint there's a there's
a lot there's a blueprint and they go
aha you're finally gonna get it a gene
is a blueprint it does not turn itself
on and off it doesn't know what it does
it doesn't know why it's needed as no
knowledge other than how to make a
protein and I go but you gave power to
the genes that's what we did oh the
genes control me and I go no
it's like the architect story there's a
blueprint blueprint doesn't work by
itself but it works with an architect
who can read the blueprint and even
modify the blueprint and I go oh well
the genes of the blueprint then who's
the architect I go our Consciousness
is ultimately translated into chemistry
that goes into the blood
and that chemistry is what controls our
genes the body provides us with
Sensations
pain love joy happiness anger whatever
it comes from this mechanism it's a
mechanism the the eyes take in light but
they don't they don't see light back
here in the brain they say energy
vibrations
sound comes in my ears I don't hear the
sound I hear the vibrations taste that's
a vibration it's a chemical vibration
all of a sense oh my God this is a
transducer it takes life experiences in
a body that gives us vision and smell
and taste and touch and pain and love
and joy and I say and this is sent back
to our source so we came here to have
life experiences and I go at that moment
of Awakening I said oh crap here's a
major difference between men and women
men are not allowed to have these
sensory experiences and I'll give you a
reason but women are so women are
sensitive and that's a way of life for
them they're sensitive and then they go
about but men are so insensitive I go
that was a program
we were programmed to be insensitive for
a very simple reason you could not be a
soldier if you're sensitive
you can't kill somebody if you're
sensitive so men have been knowingly
programmed to lose sensitivity so they
can be used to do those jobs like
killing somebody else
and I go oh my God then I miss the
reason for being on this planet I missed
the feeling of what is love all about
you know what are these senses of joy
and happiness I'm not allowed to
experience them as a guy because that
interferes with a soldier job
I go I'm wasting my life and that was a
wake-up call I said well damn it go out
and taste it and touch it and feel and
smell it and do whatever you want and if
it's really good do it again if it
didn't work out so good then don't do
that one again you came here to have
these experiences why would you want to
waste your life having all the negative
fear anxiety all those problems it was a
choice
it was consciousness
but we didn't know that because we were
programmed to be victim
and a victim has no power
and as long as you believe you're a
victim then you manifest victim
and this is why I'm so uh honored to be
with you Jeff because you're
experiencing this you know this stuff
you're trying to get this message out to
the other people why to wake us all up
because we came here to manifest heaven
on Earth like Falling in Love
and I go now what about all this war and
pestilence and plague and and all these
things I go oh that's a manifestation
and we're manifesting it
you can live in this world without even
being involved with all those things you
just have to change who you are and what
you are and what you want conscious mind
versus programs subconscious mind
and when you understand this you become
empowered and I say empowered to do what
I say create Heaven on Earth and then
people think oh you die and go to heaven
I go boy is that a big mistake because
you're going to get to the Pearly Gates
Saint Peter's going to be there and he
says well how was your experience on
Heaven he said what do you mean I said
you were on earth right that's Heaven
why that's where you came to create what
did you create they go oh
I don't want to wait to the end man
my my mother remarried when she was
relatively older and she married this
guy who was I said curmudgeony guy he
was not very happy guy or anything he
lived to be like 95 96 or something he
had cancer my mother took care of him at
home the last week of his life
essentially wasn't there he was just
comatose more or less in the bed and
then two days before he died he all of a
sudden his eyes opened up it was there
and he looked at my mother and he said I
didn't have any fun
and all of a sudden I just said holy
crap he's gonna die in two days and he
woke up today he didn't have any fun I
said that's not me babe because when I
finished it's going to be that was great
let's do it again
one of the things that really upset me
for a long time was the fact that I had
great ideas and intentions and I wanted
to manifest him and I thought this is
how it's going to manifest and so I had
all these visions of how things were
going to unfold and then I'd started
processing it wouldn't unfold and then
it would irritate me because it's like
I've got to make it work I gotta make it
work uh ultimately I started to
recognize when things didn't work
it was possibly because there were
better ways to do it and I wasn't
conscious of it and so what I started to
learn over a period of time was simply
this there's an old saying there's a
means to an end and the idea well the
end is your destination
and of course the means are how you're
going to get to that destination well of
course all of us sit down and say yeah
this is what I want and then we start to
figure out well this is what I'll do to
get to those ends I'll get to this and
I'll get to this to get to the end
what I started to realize at some point
was maybe my awareness of how to get to
the end wasn't exactly accurate and it
turns out many of the times when things
didn't work and I was like so upset it
didn't work but it turned out oh there
was a better way to get there and I
didn't even know it so the universe was
really facilitating me and I wasn't
paying attention I was getting angry at
the universe because like it's not
working in a way I want it to work
and then I started to realize some point
was my God maybe the universe has a
better solution than the one I was even
thinking of myself so I really learned
over a period of time it's very critical
insight to help me get to where I am is
to focus on them on the end what is it I
really want put that Focus together and
it's very critical it's very interesting
because a lot of people have well I
would like this and it's a broad General
category and then at some point it's
like well it's not specific enough you
have to actually say what it is you want
I'll always remember I was uh looking
for a special shirt to go to a Pink
Floyd concert and and I just all of a
sudden visualize oh it'd be neat to have
a Russian shirt you know with a collar
that goes across here and a couple of
buttons down and I thought oh yeah that
would be really great that would be cool
shirt and then I stopped and I was
thinking where the heck do you get a
shirt like that I have no idea in the
world but I thought that would be pretty
good so I figured I still got to get
something so I drive off to a mall up
near San Francisco and I walk into the
mall and there's a first men's store
over there and I go let's start looking
I have no idea and I walked in and of
course there's this big circular rack of
sale clothes and I thought what the hell
it's only a Pink Floyd concert one night
let's see what's in there and I started
going through the wreck and lo and
behold oh my God a Russian shirt right
in the middle of everything and it was
like the shock of oh my God this is a
Russian shirt right here
the enforce the unfortunate part of it
was I had the picture of a Russian chart
I said cool I never said what the color
was or anything else I just had Russian
shirt and there was a Russian shirt
color gray no color at all why I didn't
put in the concept of color and universe
said well just give it to him in Gray
and it was one of those things like oh
be conscious of what you're asking for
because the the more detail you put in
the more the universe can manifest a
resolution if you leave a lot of blanks
in what you want then all of a sudden
it's like well it's random whatever
fills in the blank because you never
said what you wanted you can have an
idea what you want and that's important
but the most important part of that just
having an idea is not just have a broad
idea I want X and I go no no what
exactly do you want why
go back to the principles of Science and
the principles of science reveal
something very important that principle
of science is this Consciousness is
creating our life experiences I go well
that sounds new agey I go no this is not
new Agee this is the primary principle
of quantum physics we are creators this
is a fact in fact uh quantum physics has
that but now let me add one other fact
epigenetics says the same thing because
epigenetics says your Consciousness is
controlling your behavior and your genes
and so it's time to stop for a second
and recognize where is your
Consciousness what are you thinking
about and the idea is start thinking all
those very positive thoughts but don't
try and tell the universe how it's going
to manifest okay you think of the
picture
let the universe get you there
and that's the most important lesson
I've learned I'm not telling the
universe how I'm going to get there I'm
just saying universe is where I want to
go
and then the universe will take care of
it it's so powerful it's so wonderful
and I never believed in it for the first
40 50 years of my life but I can tell
you now the life that I'm manifesting
today is a consequence of just what I
said focus on the end don't tell the
universe the means to get there what are
some daily affirmations you started to
implement when you saw this depressed
thoughts coming in or these
self-sabotage thoughts coming in what
did you shift it with affirmations with
different thoughts what did you start it
was just the awareness a that you know
as I said the very first stop light
where I started all of a sudden listen
while I'm waiting for the light it was
like the first time I tuned in and go
what the hell are you thinking
that was the most important thing
because then the habit of
not going there anymore starting to
realize oh this is why am I thinking is
that everything turn around make a
positive statement right now because
that negative one is taking you on the
and just a repetition of this Behavior
become habitual so and habits are great
why no effort I love habits why you
don't even have to think about them they
do it automatically you know so if you
put in these really great habits you can
walk through the day and think anything
you want do anything you want and your
habit if they're good ones will just
guide you perfectly through here without
even being involved with thinking
um that's the game the game is what has
happened to you
then program that that's your life and
then guess what the 95 of the day
manifesting Heaven what you're not even
thinking about it the most important
aspect about sleep is that it gives a
chance for the body to recalibrate its
system so when Consciousness is out then
uh the body starts to balance everything
that's going on you know with each
system the body's pH the temperature
regulation very interesting point now
when people are comatose and they're in
a hospital and they got all the wires on
them and everything they run at a
beautiful just just beautiful like
idling speed they're comatose but their
body is maintained a balance and Harmony
and everything is great in the body
level but as soon as they become awake
then the parameters in the body all
start to change because it's our
Consciousness that is creating the the
functions of our body uh and it's really
important for people to understand this
is a quantum physics is the most valid
science on this planet in regard to its
theoretical insights and the number one
principle in quantum physics is
consciousness is creating our life
experience that's the most important
understanding because it says we're not
just a a machine but we're like a remote
control machine there's a uh an energy
field that is being picked up by each of
us that is different uh the the field
that's being received is different for
each person a lack of knowledge is a
lack of power and I say you're suffering
out here because you feel you have no
power and if you really understand the
biology that we're talking about and the
spirituality that you're talking about
and you start to recognize that you
recognize oh my God you are so powerful
and yet you have a belief of victim and
since belief controls it no matter how
powerful you are if your belief is your
victim then you are a victim and we have
been victimized Eyes by beliefs that are
incorrect and uh and if we adjust the
science it automatically then comes
right together with the whole spiritual
message that agape and my brother
Reverend here uh have been providing for
years uh but there's a scientific
context to it because a lot of people go
well there's a scientific I go yes it is
I mean I mean what are all those flawed
beliefs that that we've been living
under all these years well there are
four of them yeah two of them are
actually part of darwinian theory which
I'll mention but the first one that's
really important is people have been
programming the belief that the genes
they inherited at conception are
programming the rest of their life the
the genes we didn't select them as far
as we know if you don't like the
characteristics you can't change these
genes and then we add on top of that we
say and the genes turn on and off by
themselves and all of a sudden you start
to realize then I'm not running my life
the genes are running my life oh my God
there's cancer in the family and their
genes they're going I'm gonna get a
cancer Gene and I said what's the belief
you already got the belief I'm going to
get cancer I go this is trouble right
there right right right just a little
sidebar because I love this sidebar
there's not one gene that causes cancer
cancer is not caused by a gene cancer is
caused by disharmony in your life uh
unresolved anger is the biggest one of
feeling lost left out you know not part
of something is another one that
separates you and I want people to
understand that because so many people
say oh I've got this cancer and the gene
doesn't I'm just a victim back here and
the genes took this and jeans made this
and I go stop
you are co-creating with those genes the
gene does not turn on and off and the
gene does not control things the gene
responds to the environment and if your
perception of the environment is not in
Harmony and support of your life that
disharmony is what can activate a gene a
gene is a blueprint just like in an
architect's office and I mentioned I say
go into an architect office and she's
working on a blueprint you ask her you
say hey is your blueprint on or off and
she'd look at you like are you crazy
it's a blueprint there's a on and off I
go yes DNA is a blueprint to make the
proteins of the body it cannot turn
itself on and off you need an architect
Consciousness mind is architect right
that turns the genes on and can modify
the readout of the genes Consciousness
is controlling your genetic activity the
when when people follow the fate of a
child adopted into a family where
there's cancer they find that the
adopted child will get the same family
cancer at the same probability as any of
the natural siblings so an adopted child
picks up that gets that cancer but
here's the point the adopted child came
from totally different genetics so it
was not the genetics that pushed that
cancer it was being adopted into a
family where the programming was not
giving them a wholeness health happiness
it's just uh stressful very stressful
programming and as you said stress
American Psychological Association
recognizes 90 percent of doctor visits
are stress related visits and
we don't focus on the stress that's like
oh a side thing I say no it's not a side
thing it's the number one thing that is
coming from the top down and the genes
genes are blueprints to make the
proteins of the body a hundred thousand
different proteins like building blocks
okay proteins are complex molecules and
they wear out proteins wear out all the
time so you have to replace them I said
well how do you replace this complex
molecule in the answer is DNA is a
blueprint to make a protein I go so what
I go well you go into an architect's
office and she's working on a blueprint
and I say well ask her is your blueprint
on or off she would look at you know
what are you talking about the blueprint
is so hot enough I go precisely genes
cannot turn themselves on and off they
don't self-actualize they're controlled
by environmental signals and all of a
sudden oh my god well if the environment
is controlling this and you're
programming the environment your
lifestyle in the environment and all
these other things now become the
primary controlling factor of your genes
not the genes and we have to let go
because when I was programming the doc
doctors that oh genes turn on and off
and all that stuff I was programming
that people are victims because as I
said as far as you know you didn't pick
the jeans you can't change them they
operate by themselves and so we were
programming victim and then it turns out
the new science of epigenetics it's not
victim you're the one that's actually
controlling it with your behavior if my
thoughts are distorted because of animal
soul
when I broadcast these thoughts I'm not
activating what I want I'm activating
what the program wants and I started to
realize that because the magnetic field
as you said
is shaping our experiences in this world
at this point and that's what you can
read with Magneto encephalograph you're
reading these fields which are your
thoughts and then I started to realize
when the field is ring mainly run by the
animal soul
I'm not controlling that that was the
automatic program that's a program
that's not me that's program and I
realized I could observe me doing the
program
but there's a point like you recognize
there's a point to say wait a minute
I'm the controller I don't want that
program I want to use my human soul to
run the show
and as you said same thing once you
start coming from the human soul you
override the animal soul
and that's when you become the Creator
and because of our creation not only is
information coming in but as the
magnetoencephalograph shows the
information going out and I say it
affects the world we're living in okay
that's the experience you have now but
it also goes back to the original spirit
and this is the karma
part where my life experience has
distorted my spiritual broadcast
and I said well how how do I get back
and I say
it's very simple you just have to know
who you are and this is what you said
and it's true most people have no idea
who they are they think they're this
physical body and I said that's what I
used to think when I was conventional
science
but once I understood the physics
and the role of energy and Consciousness
and spirit
the game changed for me
I said wait a minute I don't want to be
the animal soul I want to be Bruce
assault I want Bruce's to create this
not that not the program from mother and
father and culture I don't want that one
I want one and like you I started to
recognize well wait I can change I can
now I want to take the control now I
won't put my hands back on the steering
wheel I want to drive this I don't want
the program to drive this you know the
cell phone that you have in your hand
yeah you can drive it by talking into it
but it also can work by itself because
it's got programming and I think that
you and I have this information that
we've been trying to present to the
world to say take back the control
because you're more than this body wow
looking at the world and seeing what's
going on right now all the chaos the
upheaval that's going on is so
distressing at one level and it's
interesting for me because as a
scientist I can stand up and talk about
the fact that today's chaos is a
necessary requirement for the evolution
that we would love to see and yet I like
you have to live in this crazy world
it's mind-blowing it's crazy and it
becomes really important because all of
this stuff that we're hearing is
motivating fear and fear by its
definition is disempowering because when
you're in fear you're expressing I have
no power to take care of myself and we
give up power and we give it up to other
people to create the world for us and
obviously by looking at this computer
and watching what's going on around the
world those so-called leaders are not
really helping us get to the destination
of a heaven on Earth reality
and it's time to recognize yes fear
takes away our power I've talked about
that in many many lectures talked about
the fact that stress hormones actually
shut down our Consciousness and puts us
into a reactive mode
well this is not a time for reaction
this is a time for creation
and this is what the emphasis of quantum
physics has been telling us that our
Consciousness that is making creation
and yet if we're living in fear and
Consciousness is coming from Fear then
what world are we creating well that's
the chaos we observe every day on the
news so in this situation what we really
have to do is just listen to the words
of Franklin D Roosevelt when he said
the only thing we have to fear is fear
itself
also relevant today are the profound
words by Frank Herbert in Dune where he
says fear is the mind killer and this is
what we have to recognize well I've been
talking about the fact that
Consciousness is created in a world and
I say it's based on science well let me
give you a very important fact it was in
1927 in the founding of the science of
quantum physics that we get the most
important Insight from one of the
founding fathers of quantum physics Max
Planck and what does Max say all matter
originates and exists only by virtue of
a force we must assume behind that Force
the existence of a conscious and
intelligent mind
he concludes this mind
is the Matrix of all matter
well that was what 70 some more years
ago or 100 years ago I say has that
changed I go no look at this for example
this is an article out of the most
prestigious scientific journal on this
planet nature and I say what's this
article I said it's called the mental
Universe it's by a Quantum physicist at
Johns Hopkins University I'm not going
to go and describe by everything he says
in the article because Richard Khan
Henry the author summed it up in the
last sentence let me emphasize for you
that last sentence in this article on
quantum physics
the universe is IMM material
it's mental and spiritual an interesting
thing about the Matrix is that we're
given a choice to take either a red pill
or a blue pill taking the red pill wakes
us up and the blue pill puts us back to
sleep those that have taken to Red Pill
believe they really have awakened but
the fact is this biologically speaking
how do you know whether you're really
awake or whether you're still asleep
what are the main limiting beliefs that
you just hear consistently that most
people tend to have if they're not in a
have a a higher level program that
they've caught and switched with well
one of the main beliefs that they're
caught up in is the lack of power they
feel over their own health and their own
reality that I'm a victim I'm a victim
of my genes I'm a victim of this world
out here I say if you if the belief
system is translated into Behavior if I
believe I'm a victim then my behavior
will be as a victim no power you guys
tell me what to do and I'll try and do
what you just said and I say well that's
the biggest problem of all because
quantum physics I mentioned is the most
valid science and principle number one
is you're the creator of this it's like
well when are you going to own that and
the answer is I could say it but then
you walk away and a few minutes later
you're back into your world again
everything is gone you know listen it
took me a while uh I learned and
understood that oh my God this is how it
works and I was so excited I wanted to
get people are going to tell anybody to
listen to this man this is how it works
so I beginning got some people together
and I started to go up let me tell you
how to create the most beautiful life
experience and then they'd look at me
and go you know Lipton for a guy who
says you know this your life doesn't
look that good interesting it was my
wake-up call that said how the hell can
I talk about how wonderful this is and
I'm not practicing it and I immediately
said to myself
no don't go out there and talk to
anybody about this why until you do it
so what were they what were the things
that were holding you back
before you've discovered this and then
what was the new program that you
started to implement for yourself on a
consistent basis to have a hundred
percent upgraded program yeah well uh
one of the things professionally okay I
was doing a great job I I had a great
professorship in a medical school all
that kind of stuff you know personally
my life sucked really put a relationship
off the ground I go why not I go well
now that I know about it I was
programmed about relationships by
observing my father and my mother
well they had dysfunctional
relationships so what do you think I
downloaded dysfunction yeah so my
conscious mind goes forward and says
yeah I want to have a great relationship
I get into it my subconscious mind steps
up and says oh this is how we do a
relationship you oh
game over you know why because I didn't
see the negative behaviors that I was
putting out my partner potential partner
saw them and gave them calls for alarm I
don't think I want to be with this guy
you know that was me and then I realized
that and that's when I really had to go
in first thing and start to change so
who am I and I'll tell you the biggest
problem
uh now after years of working
people do not love themselves
um
and I say what does that mean I said if
you have a program where you don't love
yourself then rationally logically
can anybody else love you and the answer
is no because you don't think you're
lovable that's right and somebody says
you are that oh I love you and then you
go well you know you probably don't have
any quality control I know I'm not
lovable what's wrong with you you know
and then at some point you push them
away and then they're not there then you
go
I'm not lovable nobody's here I push
them away you know and I changed that I
was nearly what 45 years old 40
something years old and I had zero
quality relationships for all that life
right to change the program
and within a couple of years I I'm now
with my partner Margaret and and the
fact is she was involved with a workshop
training program for people so she
understood processing and stuff and when
I came and we added the science and the
processing uh we've been living a
honeymoon for 26 years really years
waking up every day going wow still here
another day for fun another day for
being in love it was great and it still
is but if I didn't change the program
that would never have been part of my
life at all I would have been my whole
life struggling well I could live in a
perfectly healthy happy environment that
will support me but if I perceive it's a
negative environment then my cells
inside my body do not know that it is a
healthy environment they only see the
perception that I send to them and this
is why perception becomes so important
is because the cells are not directly
touching the environment and depend on
the nervous systems interp rotation
to adjust their biology so if I change
my perception my mind changed my belief
about life I changed the signals that
are going in and adjusting the function
of the cell
point is very very significant and that
is this I'm not a victim of my genes
because I by my ability to change my
environment and by my ability to change
my perception of the environment have
the ability to control my genetic
activity I'm not a victim of my heredity
I'm a master of my genetic activity well
how do you change a program that was the
issue not how you change the conscious
mind how do you change the subconscious
mind because it doesn't learn conscious
mind learns by just whatever you read
the book I learned it okay subconscious
mind doesn't learn that way I say how
does it learn I say well in the first
seven years that's when I said the
programming went in the brain wasn't
functioning at the higher level of
Consciousness it was actually a little
lower that was called Theta the
vibration the imagination and all that
that's hypnosis okay so the first way we
learned programs was hypnosis because
the the the function of the brain wasn't
it was at a low uh you know lower
vibration some people might remember the
old days when hypnotherapy they they'd
have a watch and the hypnotherapist said
you know swing the watch back and forth
and they would say you're getting tired
you're getting tired uh and what was the
point
when you get tired you lower the
vibration of the brain and the moment
you fall asleep actually consciously the
next level of activity of the brain is
Theta before it goes down to the lowest
vibration Delta sleep so every night
when you go to bed there's a period just
after you close your eyes and you're
essentially disconnected for a moment
your brain is operating in Theta well
Theta is hypnosis okay so I said well
that's how you you your brain was in
Theta during that childhood period as
predominantly now you're an adult I said
yeah but you have Theta every night when
you go to bed so I said what can you do
and this is the old story you've heard
people do it you put a pair of earphones
on at night you play a program that you
want to be true in your life and while
you're awake you might hear the program
but it's the moment you fall asleep the
conscious mind shut off but the
subconscious mind is now in record Theta
so whatever is coming through the
earphones at that moment after you fall
asleep you don't hear it but the
subconscious mind is here hearing it and
downloading it in a state of theta so
the first way of changing a belief
system is to get into Theta and this is
called self-hypnosis put the earphones
on play the program programs for health
happiness love joy whatever and just go
to sleep which is really cool because
you don't have any there's no studying
here you just play the program five
percent of the day we move toward wishes
desires what we want even you know the
addict is like yeah I don't want this
this is not my life I really want this
and and all that and then I say yeah but
that only works five percent of the day
95 a day you're coming from The Habit
yeah but the Habit was other people's
behavior that you put into the
subconscious first and so 95 of the day
you're not operating from your wishes
and desires you're operating from a
program sure okay but now here's the
catch and then we'll get we'll get on to
it and that is this
by definition if I am thinking all of a
sudden I say what am I doing next one is
I go to my head and I'm thinking about
what I'm doing uh what's on Wednesday by
definition I'm not paying attention to
what's going on so that doesn't mean
like you're walking down the street you
have a thought and then you freeze while
the thought happens and then after the
thought then you start walking back down
the street again no if you're walking
down the street and you have a thought
the moment you have a conscious mind
engaged in thought it the functions are
defaulted to the subconscious program so
in other words I know how to walk that's
a habit I learned that so I don't need
my conscious mind to tell me how to walk
so my conscious mind goes in thought I'm
still walking so whatever behavior I'm
doing driving a car I don't have to pay
attention to what's going on when I'm
driving a car I mean the the joke when I
lecture about is I say look you know
I've been in a car with a passenger we
get so engaged in a conversation my
conscious mind is tied up with the
conversation and then all of a sudden I
look out the window of the car and it
Dawns on me I paid attention to the road
for the last five minutes how did I get
home yeah and and here's what the knee
part is well look driving is once you
practice and learn how to drive practice
makes habit habit means that the
subconscious mind doesn't need you to
explain how to drive and what to watch
out for subconscious Minds already got
the program it's called Rory McIlroy who
uh he was leading the Masters Golf
Tournament a few years back he had a big
lead and you know this is just one
example I'm not having to go Rory this
is just it's common in all sports where
um
people almost self-implate and for a few
holes
like he could barely swing the golf club
what was really interesting is as always
sort of reading a lot of Bowser trying
to figure out what's going on here it's
this conscious subconscious again where
he knows how to drive the golf ball you
know better than most people on the
planet yes so he's playing usually from
his subconscious the patterns around he
knows how to shake the ball right to
left left to right whatever
but in that moment where it's like oh
man I'm leading the Masters I need to be
really careful now he's trying to think
you know or something this is what
people say I don't know what was in his
minds but you're almost overthinking
you're now trying to control something
that you could naturally do as you say
driving yeah if you were thinking about
when do I put the clutch down or what
timing is it with the accelerator you
know if you if you drive a manual it's
it's the same kind of thing isn't it
absolutely but in fact really when when
he's playing the game he's playing it in
the conscious mind in the sense that he
has a vision I'm going to hit this ball
and it's going to go into that hole over
there he very important because
you there's a destination
and there's a means to that destination
it turns out and this is really most
important is if you focus on the
destination and not on the means let the
system which is so powerful to it will
get there without you telling it how to
get there but when you start to
interfere and say okay now I got to make
sure I swing it right my head's level my
grip is right and all of a sudden you're
putting all those details in it's like
no don't focus on the details you forgot
what the end was the end was the ball is
supposed to go over and there and so
that starts to come in because now
you're trying to control everything with
your you know with this manual control
and it's like no uh you don't have to
have the manual control matter of fact
that gets in the way the body knows what
you want you don't have to tell it how
to get there that's a big issue in our
lives because uh I want to be successful
how oh I got to do this I gotta do this
and I say oh you're you're planning all
these things uh and you're you're
conscious mind is not even any the
subconscious a million times more
powerful a computer than the conscious
mind so I say you're going to take this
little small conscious mind and try to
run the bigger computer it's like that
doesn't work let go of the control and
this is the whole thing I mean it's a I
I just came to my mind a lot of people
say let go let God or something like
there's some phrase that people always
say and I go well that's actually the
way to do it focus on what you want but
don't try and tell the universe how it's
going to happen don't tell them that I'm
going to do this and this is going to
happen I go no you just focus on what
you want the intelligence of this super
computer the subconscious super computer
uh it will handle it unless you put your
hands into the machine I said Keep Your
Hands on the machine focus on where that
ball is going to go I mean he already
practiced remember I said we did The
Habit we did the practice whether you're
driving a car or hitting the golf ball
practice practice you don't think about
the details of driving when you're
driving you know they just automatically
you could have conversation you could be
often thought and you're still driving
the car here's a simple truth the first
40 years was struggle life
when I did this ik and all that stuff
the last 30 years has been the most
enjoyment I could ever imagine in life
that I even wrote a book called the
honeymoon effect because the the harmony
of what love brings into the world you
know and people are on a honeymoon it's
like heaven on Earth and I say for 30
years I've been living heaven on Earth
and and every aspect of my life is so
beautiful and why
I changed the limiting programs through
the process of psyche
and when I put in programs that gave me
the values I wanted the joy which is so
really important about it is I didn't
have to work on it once the program was
in there the subconscious running 95 of
the day automatically without my even
participating consciously I was Finding
heaven without even making an effort to
get there and I am living in this most
wonderful life no doctors no
pharmaceutical drugs no insurance you
either no me either well I'm sure I
spend the money for insurance I haven't
had Insurance since 1992. yeah I haven't
either and and the fact is what
who needs it I'm not I'm not planning to
do that right and the idea is what we
really ultimately come down to is life
isn't a bunch of accidents that we move
through life is a bunch of creations and
if your life is a struggle uh we always
have a tendency to say oh the universe
is against me or something like that I'm
a victim I can't oh it's out of my
control it's that's the problem not me
and once you understand the basis of the
new biology and the psyche process you
start to recognize why I am a co-creator
of my life and if my programs are not
really good then my life will not be
really good changing those programs and
here I am today with you and look how
beautiful this woman is she Sparkles and
shines why when we clean up the the
problems that we acquired in our
development
then life comes to us you don't even
have to go out and Chase it anymore and
that is the 100 difference first 40
years I'm gonna go get out success last
30 years open the door oh here you are
thank you very much yeah yeah so uh all
I say is the most exciting experience of
my life was to Take Back Control Bruce
do you have uh in your work a general
perspective on or a definition or a way
that you look at addiction
well basically what I have to understand
about biology is that throughout
Evolution biological systems are given
information in response to how they how
they deal with the world around them we
call them emotions Sensations feelings
symptoms Etc like that one of the major
aspects is this is that nature is
designed uh two senses of pain and
pleasure as a way of teaching an
organism to go in the right direction in
other words we're smart we go to school
we learn you know across the street look
both ways and all that kind of stuff
like that but you got smaller lower
forms of life animals that are moving
through the world how do they know where
to go and where not to go how to to do
the right thing to stay alive well
nature uh has endowed them with a sense
of feeling and the significance about
that is we are given two completely
opposite senses one is pain and one is
pleasure when pleasure is received by an
organized are more perceived by an
organism it really represents that
you're doing the right thing and that's
why nature encourages you says look this
is really good go this way but when you
start to do something that threatens
your survival or is it really not
supportive we receive a sensation of
pain and that's Nature's way of saying
look this is threatening to you this is
you know inappropriate behavior whatever
it is do something different
and it's kind of interesting because uh
in our civilization and throughout
history that was manipulated a bit by by
the original Church which looked at uh
pleasure as negative and pain is
positive which is like complete
turnaround of the table of biology some
confusing messages there absolutely but
it it really causes a a profound
conflict in our biology when our biology
is telling us we're doing something
right gives us pleasure and then our
psychology is saying no no that's wrong
don't do that uh then we have a conflict
between programming and biology and so
basically what I see is this is that
when we find ourselves in trauma and
problems uh a we try to seek a way to
get out if you can't seek a way to get
out then you actually do some kind of
other Behavior or something else to uh
to lessen the pain because uh if you
can't move and you're stuck in pain then
what are you supposed to do just living
that well at our level of cognition and
awareness we can put in some other
behavior and and and and and and then
actually uh override the the current
experience so what we have to recognize
is when people really are generally
dealing with an addiction problem
they're really first trying to overcome
some kind of pain in their life or
threat to their survival or their
existence and then choose another
alternative Behavior unfortunately the
alternative behaviors don't necessarily
take you out of the problem so you stay
in the problem uh but even though you're
trying to get mentally out of the
problem knowledge is power and lack of
knowledge is a lack of power when people
don't know that they're involved with
their own life and their own genetics
and their own behavior because they're
programmed to be the victim then they
become a victim because they have no
knowledge of this and and what you're
doing what I'm doing is let's wake up
you are powerful if you understand how
this works and if you don't understand
how it works you just say no it's not me
I'm not in control and and people walk
away feeling like there's nothing I can
do the genes are controlling this and I
don't control the genes I go well that's
the story that's wrong and when people
are allowed to walk away from a medical
practitioner with that belief then that
practitioner in no way has helped that
patient because the idea is this as you
said I've got to help them get a better
attitude when they walk out of this
building I have to give them more power
so that they have more power because if
they walk out saying there's nothing I
can do then the game is over at that
point what is happening right now in the
world in society that you see where
things are are ramping up or are they
or and why is it more more important now
than ever go ahead okay uh we're in the
process of an evolutionary upheaval at
this very this very time moment and the
upheaval is due to crises and we see the
crisis around the world whether it's
economic religious racial whatever you
want I say those are trees in a forest
and I said if you get back a little
further away you can see the bigger
crisis is uh we are facing an imminent
Extinction of human civilization uh and
and this is real uh and the public has
been made aware of it a long time ago
and then sort of disappeared that we are
facing what is called the sixth mass
extinction of Life on this planet which
means five times uh there were previous
mass extinctions and and the point about
we always think evolution is one
continuous you know from beginning to
end it's like no it starts stops breaks
starts again stops breaks and it's done
five times the last uh Mass extensions
66 million years ago when the dinosaurs
were here and a comet hit near Mexico up
ended the web of life and then all of a
sudden 75 percent of uh all species
disappeared uh when that after that
Comet uh but today we're in What's
called the sixth mass extinction and why
we're bringing it here Abraham and Tara
is basically because science is
recognized for the last oh my God 15
years or more that human civilization
human behavior is undermining the Web of
Life leading to our own Extinction
uh and just is there a number I'll give
you an interesting number the uh World
Wildlife Foundation in 1970 took a
survey how many animals on planet Earth
they recently redid the survey
two-thirds of the entire animal
population of the planet has disappeared
since the first time they did it uh
we're losing species of organism faster
than in some previous as I said five
mass extinctions significance is this
human behavior is now has been
recognized as the cause of this we are
undermining our environment uh thinking
that we are you know a dominant in
control of the environment no we are the
environment you you know uh the you know
the Grandeur of human thinking is a weak
in control and dominate nature is like
well how's that working the answer is
facing mass extinction the next few
decades period so we have to change
Behavior that's why when I say it's on
my lectures I say okay how many people
in here have read a self-help book and
all the hands go up I say okay now how
many of you your lives changed after you
read the self-help book all the hands go
back down I said what's this and the
issue is this
you educated your conscious mind the
creative mind by reading a book
but the subconscious mind doesn't learn
that way and it's very important it's
resistant to change why if I learned a
habit I don't want it to change every
day if I learned how to walk I don't
want to have to re-learn how to walk all
the time I if I learned how to do it
then fine so that basically says then
the subconscious mind is resistant to
change
I say number one so what so what happens
how does it do it like if you're if
you're sober then I have years I have to
go back and say well how did you educate
the conscious mind the subconscious mind
in the first place I go first seven
years hypnosis that's what the brain was
in Theta was just downloading programs
bypassing Consciousness conscious our
conscious Minds did not filter the
download of the programs and it's a good
program bad program what conscious mind
wasn't working when the downloads were
going so I just got programs conscious
mind wasn't even there doesn't even have
any idea of it so yeah
the next issue is this okay your brain
is in hypnosis for first seven years but
your subconscious still learns programs
after you're seven I say how does it
learn it then I go oh habituation
repetition repeat the behavior over and
over and over again whether that's a
healthy Behavior or an unhealthy
Behavior you'll learn a new pattern
depending on what you practice
absolutely because the the function of
that mind is to take pattern that is re
played over and over again and then
acquired that's why look you want to
learn how to drive a car practice drive
a car you want to go back this one this
is a learning our ABCs go back to
Childhood how long did it take you to
get from A to Z and the answer was how
many times did you start a b c
a b c d e
and then you repeated it you repeated it
you repeated it and finally you got the
Z what was the result I never had to do
it again I habituated it because I
repeated it over and over and over again
that's how I learned how many times did
I repeat the times table in school uh
whatever issue on a job I learned to do
the job I learned how to communicate all
these different things so uh basically
how'd you do that repetition I think
this is one of the best things that we
both can do right now is to help people
recognize how truly powerful they are
even though they've been programmed and
saying I'm a victim I say no you're not
and there's a science behind it and
that's why I love talking with you
because there's the spiritual part which
I never was spiritual for 40 years I was
a Science Guy James chromosomes blah
blah blah and then in the study of the
cells the cells taught me that we're not
even in here we're broadcast playing
through here and and when you understand
why which was which blew my mind because
hey I wasn't spiritual and all of a
sudden I said oh my goodness the cells
have little antennas on them and each of
us has a different set of these antennas
which are receiving a broadcast yes in
physics you might say the word field
which is uh let me Define it invisible
moving forces that influence the
physical world and I go
same definition for Spirit invisible
moving forces influence the physical
world I said oh my God quantum physics
is revealed to us that we're this energy
spirit and we come in and play through
the body and our each of our bodies have
a different sets of antennas so no two
people get the same station and all of a
sudden I realize oh my God you know
after 40 some years of not even
believing in it in two minutes I turn
around go of course everything is
spiritual now
the meaning of it for me Michael was so
great because you know what happened
yeah you had you had a kind of an
instantaneous like Epiphany it just
changed your life the lightning hit me
yeah uh and and what was interesting
within seconds
I lost fear
um because I understand that because the
greatest fear of people have is death
yes what if you don't die because the
field is always here whether the body
which I call the television set right
watching the Bruce show on the
television set here but the Bruce I was
a broadcast being picked up and played
through the show and I realized uh you
can't die you're not even in here right
where the energy around here
and then but then you know being a
inquisitive scientists I I remember I'll
never forget it I sat there it's just
like oh my God there's a spirit and
there's a body and a spirit and my
science mind said why not just be a
spare why I have a body and then I found
out I had what I referred to as Jewish
comedian cells because I I asked a
question why have both a body and a
spirit and the cells answered with a
question that came right up in my head
and the answer is like it's so profound
and so funny I said why have a spider in
the body and the and the cell said Bruce
if you're just a spirit what does
chocolate taste like
now you have to take that one in for a
little bit and realize something is that
this body
translates energy environments into
pictures and sounds and smells and
feelings uh and all these things and I
go oh my God we came here to experience
life people have heard of the phrase use
it or lose it and frequently they're
referring to oh well I can build up my
muscles through exercise and I'm using
them but if I stop using my muscles then
disappear and I go use it or lose it
applies to every system in the human
body every system is based on use or
lose it and most importantly the
creative aspect of a child is when they
were in child development that's what
kids do they they create ideas they play
and through play they are being very
creative but if we are doing what we're
doing now and that is programming them
with uh STEM Science technology
engineering math uh I say those courses
are not creative those courses are rote
memorization can you memorize the
equation can you memorize this and I go
if what has happened is our education
has taken the creative part out because
of finances oh yeah uh years ago when I
went to school we had Great Courses we
we you know we had shop for the you know
for the guys or everybody want to learn
how to fix and make things you know uh
home Mech uh we had music we had art
these are programs and most of those
have been sacrificed in budgetary
reasons to provide more stem and I say
then what have you thrown out of the
education I said the creative part of a
child's education has now been
transferred to the rote memorization of
science technology and engineering and I
say and the result is this we are not as
creative as a population uh not that
long ago okay well it is long ago
because I'm old but uh the the US was a
leader in technology we because we had
the best education system that provided
creativity for the kids to you know to
move into the future today the US is
somewhere near the bottom of Western
countries in regard to technology why
we've lost our creative character uh use
it or lose it we've lost it and this is
a wake-up call giving children back the
exercises of creativity because that's
what engages those brain cells and if
you don't engage those brain cells then
they don't develop and use it or lose it
applies the most important thing about
transcending a program as I mentioned
before is identifying what the program
is and that's why I wanted to give
people an insight to their own
programming by just reviewing their life
and recognizing things you like come in
because you have a program things you
desire that don't don't come in is
because you have a program that doesn't
support that and I say well how do you
change these programs uh and I said
there's three fundamental ways to change
a program and it's very critical because
the subconscious mind is a habit mind
the conscious mind is a creative mind I
go what's the difference I say habit by
definition doesn't want to change I mean
if a habit changes then it's not a habit
anymore so I say first issue is this the
programs that we were downloaded with
are habits they were put into our mind
before age seven and then we just play
them like a push the button play the
program push the button play the program
not all habits are bad a matter of fact
you wouldn't like it without a
subconscious I'll give the example when
did you learn how to walk you learned
how to walk before you were two you
could be a hundred and two you're still
walking I go why that habit is there and
it doesn't change then so the first
thing we have to recognize habits are
not like open hey just change me you
actually have have to like push a record
button to get into that habit I go well
how do you get a habit I said well how
did we get a habit in our life I said
for the first seven years we were in a
state of consciousness called Theta
which is hypnosis and we downloaded it
uh and the relevance about that is uh
Theta is a lower vibration than
conscious which is Alpha and focus
Consciousness Beta And I go so why is it
relevant because because when we are
working like right now we're in beta
High Focus Consciousness School room
kind of working like that but when we go
home and relax the vibration slows down
that's called Alpha so we're in a calmer
consciousness
but what people have to recognize is
this the moment you close your eyes like
I'm just going to sleep Consciousness
switch went off I'm not in an alpha I
just dropped into Theta I go well
Consciousness is closed but Theta is
hypnosis so if you put earphones on and
you go to bed uh and you put the
earphones on and there's a program
playing through those earphones of
things that you want to be true in your
life uh you might hear some of the
program while you're still awake but the
moment Consciousness disconnects you're
in a zone of theta before you go to the
lowest vibration Delta which is absolute
sleep so every night there's a window of
opportunity putting earphones on as soon
as your conscious mind goes to sleep the
subconscious mind is going to take
whatever's coming in those earphones and
begin to download them because that is
hypnosis so that's self-hypnosis but
that by age seven changes because by age
seven now we spend more time in
Consciousness than in Theta uh and I go
but we still learn things you learn how
to drive a car you learn how to practice
with an instrument you learn all these
things I say why is it relevant in the
answers simply this how did you create a
habit practice you practiced it so the
second way of changing a program is
practice a new life if you don't like
the one you have uh yeah I like a new
age of people fake it till you make it I
go yeah what does that mean I said well
I'm a miserable person I want to be
happy so I said but you're not happy I
said yeah but fake it what does that
mean I say all day long anytime you can
just consciously pass by you say oh I am
happy I am happy you could be miserable
I don't really care the idea is I am
happy I am happy repetition practice is
how you make habits and so if you keep
saying all day long I'm happy I'm happy
and you say it for a period of time
because it's habit practice there's a
day you wake up and you already started
happy because the program is already in
there you don't even have to do it
anymore less than one listen less than
one percent of disease is connected to
genes I go where the hell is all the
disease coming from
90 Plus
of disease
is stress
and and all of a sudden oh so I said
well you can relieve all the take all
the cancer cells out I said did you get
rid of the stress no oh well then guess
what it's coming back
because that the cells didn't cause the
problem they are a symptom of a problem
and with all diseases like
cardiovascular disease 90 has nothing to
do with genes you're not living in
harmony you're living in fear a lot of
it has a fear is the greatest cause of
stress because fear means I'm powerless
that's what fear means oh my God
something's coming I I'm a victim I am
powerless somebody help me and then the
pharmaceutical company comes and goes
we're here to help you I go another line
of BS wave says
pharmaceutical company isn't here to
help you it's a company it's a
corporation I say give me the rule
number one rule in law when you make a
corporation what is the number one rule
in the corporation's leadership and the
answer is your job is to make a profit
for the shareholder that's number one if
a corporation is not making a profit for
the shareholder then it falls apart
doesn't work anymore so I said well how
do you make a profit for the shareholder
I say gotta make a lot of money I go
well making a lot of money does that
mean you're going to help a lot of
people I go
well tell them we'll help them we'll
sell them with drugs and they'll buy the
drugs and then we're going to make a lot
of money I'll say do the drugs really
work I go how many people are out there
because the doctor said your blood
pressure is high or your cholesterol
level is high and we're going to have to
give you statins statin drugs I go how
long do I do I have to take a
prescription of satin drugs and then the
doctor goes how long do you want to live
oh you want to live then take that and
Drug your whole life I go
I can't take my whole life I said are
they gonna help me now comes the truth
statin drugs only helped three out of
100 people
97 people out of 100 have no positive
effect from certain drugs in fact over
20 of those people will have side
effects that are disastrous so wait I
took the statin drugs to help me with my
cholesterol level three people are going
to be helped 20 people are going to get
sicker I go well maybe we shouldn't sell
the stat of drugs they go are you
kidding me man that's a prescription for
life that means we have a customer for a
life
and I go nobody paid attention to the
side effects being more dangerous than
the the healing effect I go people don't
care because they're told whatever the
advertisement told them drug companies
they don't give a damn why because the
97 people that Deb no positive effect
from satins are going to pay them every
day of their life to take a satin drug I
say is it going to help them I go nope
but they're going to pay for it every
day and the drug company's like yay
I could sell lots of Silent drugs and
you know what they did to sell more
drugs because there was a cholesterol
level and it said if you're above this
cholesterol level you need a Statin drug
like then what'd they do they kept
changing the cholesterol level over time
it was no no you have to have less
cholesterol oh all of a sudden it said
people that you know had a certain level
of cholesterol below the required part
no I don't have to take statin drugs
then I said no no you need a cholesterol
down here oh now that many more people
are going to take stock and drugs every
time they lowered the amount of
cholesterol to another level there's a
whole new cohort of people that are
going to buy the Statin drug because oh
it used to be oh that cholesterol level
was okay now it's not okay now you've
got to take the drug because they kept
lowering the level and every time they
lower the level there's a million new
customers for statin drugs did it help
absolutely not the side effects were far
greaters like five seven times greater
side effects than healing what is the
immune system well generally it's
something that protects me from what
from things that get inside your body
body
and I said well why should things want
to get inside my body in the first place
let's set up a scenario
you're out there in the world and I drop
you off in the wilderness and I say okay
survive
and one of the things you have to do is
start finding food and you're going to
spend all your time maybe find nothing
and you're going to be looking for food
and here's an alternative Vision I drop
you out and eat all you can Buffet well
you don't have to worry about food
that's being served to you all the time
what does this have to do with the
immune system and I go like this
bacteria parasites that live out in the
environment have to struggle for their
survival to find food
but underneath your skin the tissues
inside your body are flush with fluid
from the blood and in that fluid are all
the nutrients and elements necessary for
growth so if a bacteria can find itself
inside to your body it would be sitting
pretty all I'd have to just sit there
and food would be constantly delivered
from an individual circulatory system
so the idea is well yeah then obviously
this is a nice environment that invasive
organisms would like to find themselves
in because it's like free food what you
know no probs so okay so what does this
mean it says well then we have to have a
defense system because if invasive
organisms get in there not only will
they utilize the food we make but they
could create a toxic waste environment
that could actually undermine our health
so we can't afford to have invasive
organisms come into us and take over and
the immune system's job is an internal
protection system as opposed to for
example the adrenal system fight or
flight which protects you from threats
on the outside immune system protects
you from threats on the inside so I said
well how does it work well the immune
system is an intelligent system because
what is the function of the immune
system to go out into the world of their
body and look for things that are new
that came in and then not only recognize
them but learn about them so that they
could create antibodies for example to
effectively knock them out so the immune
system's character is learning and
memory I go wow what a coincidence this
is the character of the nervous system
point
the immune system is an extension of the
nervous system learning in memory about
the environment in which you live so I
said well how does it work well I say
that there are organisms that prefer to
find the interior of our body as a place
to live because it's so much easier for
them just to sit there and live off of
your energy and your nourishment so the
old story is oh the immune system
protects self my body against invading
organisms as everything else is called
knob cell well I go that's a crude
Insight but it's not anywhere near
accurate for a simple reason
the immune system identifies things that
get into the body that cause disruption
of the system and its job is to identify
them mark them and eliminate them and I
go but there you know there are many
organisms that live with us that are
part of us it's called the microbiome
thousands of species of organisms
bacteria and parasites living with us I
say the immune system doesn't attack
them the reason is this they support our
viability they support who we are so
self versus not self that's not the
discriminating Factor the immune system
factor of the immune system is anything
that's disruptive to the system well
guess what that not only includes
organisms that come from the outside but
even our own cells if they go Rogue like
go into a cancer State the immune
system's job is to eliminate them so
basically the functional immune system
is to keep Harmony in the system any
organism that comes in that disrupts
Harmony functions immune system
eliminated energy psychology is a new
version of psychology that engages
something called super learning super
learning what's that I go maybe seeing
somebody read a book by moving their
finger down the page just as fast as
they move that finger down the page they
read everything about you know on the
page on both Pages boom they could just
read it so the idea is this well if you
can engage super learning
and use that in downloading a new
Behavior ready you can change the belief
you had your whole life 50 60 years you
can change that in minutes
because super learning is the equivalent
of pushing the record button on on the
subconscious super learning allows you
to download a new program in minutes and
we need that why because the behavior
that the culture and civilization using
today is so out of harmony with nature
that humans are causing their own
Extinction at this moment it's called a
mass extinction NASA scientists have
have already told us that industrial
civilization the one we're in
uh is facing and I want to emphasize
this because it was in the title of
their report and I just I said we are
facing an
irreversible collapse of civilization in
the next couple of decades well we're
seeing it right now civilization is not
working the chaos that's all over the
planet is a sign that it does not work
this way and if we don't change then
we're facing our own Extinction what do
you mean by being able to change inner
Evolution because we all really do
believe that genes are destiny
well the biggest story comes down to
knowledge is power and everyone goes
yeah we all knowledge is power but let
me put it in a better way for us now a
lack of knowledge is a lack of power
and a misperception by definition is a
lack of knowledge and now I have to say
we have been for the last 50 years
operating under two very uh important
misperceptions a the one you brought up
genes control our life this is totally
false uh and the second one is actually
uh the idea of a Newtonian universe
that's split into physical matter and
and visible energy in two different
Realms and they don't communicate and
whatever is physical should be you know
interfered with by something that's
physical so that's why we have
pharmaceutical drugs we have a physical
body you want to fix it you have to give
it something physical so those are the
drugs and that's an outdated and
disempowering illusion because it turns
out it's energy and Consciousness that
shape the world and and and let me just
emphasize it so it's not so it's a weird
sounding yes Consciousness our mind is
creating this well quantum physics is to
me the most valid science on the planet
being before it was fully understood the
theoretical ideas that were presented
have all been actually realized that uh
the that this is such an amazing science
quantum physics and I say so what's
relevant about this valid science I go
the first principle in quantum physics
is consciousness is creating our life
experiences and uh you know that's oh
that's so new age I go no that's about
as hardcore science as there is and uh
this Consciousness and and this is why I
love working with you Lynn because your
job has been raising Consciousness
around the world and that is how we're
going to evolve is not physically
evolved but we're going to evolve with
Consciousness and so uh the knowledge
that you're providing for people is
empowering and I like to do the same
stress hormones shut off the immune
system
okay so that's two problems right away
growth maintenance shut off by blood
vessel squeezing shut immune system
stress hormones directly inhibit the
immune system so I'm not putting energy
in to internal problem when I'm being
chased and then I I always call the
third one the insult to the injury you
just injured your body now you will know
what the insult is I told you the stress
hormones and the in the gut squeeze shut
when you're in fear that's a butterflies
in the stomach you can feel it it says
queasy queasy and I go what else the
stress hormone shut the blood vessels
off in the thinking brain back right
here the the prefrontal cortex and when
the blood is squeezed the blood vessels
are squeezed out here the blood is
pushed to the hind brain that's where
reflexes occur and reactions occur no
thinking
so guess what
under stress you shut down thinking and
now you're just reacting and I go so
you've lost the power of your
Consciousness it's not working the
subconscious mind is one million times
more powerful and works 95 percent of
the time versus the small conscious mind
working five percent I said that's the
one that's stressed that's the one
that's struggling it says I want
something and I'm not getting it and I'm
going to make it and I go you're trying
to change the world when your own
behavior was the one that was sabotaging
it and that's because you didn't see
your programs and like Bill you engage
these programs and you don't even know
you have these programs but then as I
said well if you want to see your
programs your life 95 coming from the
program your life is a printout of your
programs
the things you like as I said they come
in they came in because you have a
program to acknowledge them but if you
understand the things you struggle over
are not because the outside is
preventing you from getting there it was
your own invisible 95 of the day playing
programs you didn't even know you had
and that's where the sabotage comes from
and yet we want to blame and fix
everybody on the outside and think that
we're just a recipients of all this
without recognizing we're the creator of
all this and that sounds like oh so new
agey and I go listen quantum physics is
the most valid science on this planet
and principle number one quantum physics
Consciousness is creating our life
experiences you want to change your life
you don't change the world you change
your own Consciousness the world changes
after that whatever you're waiting for
be a peace of mind contentment Health it
will surely come but only when you're
ready to receive it with openness and
gratitude
of all the characteristics needed for
both a happy and morally decent life
none surpasses gratitude happiness and
health are the just rewards for living
and gratitude
wow I remember the first time I read
that I doubted that gratitude could give
me health and happiness but now I know
differently
Igor Igor house
party later
ah yes another year would be wonderful
ah
well you know what
that whole story that Ben Franklin told
us about gratitude and health well it
actually works and now scientifically we
know why because built into every one of
ourselves is the Fountain of Youth
well what's the Fountain of Youth in the
South well it's something called
telomeres telomeres they are special
parts of the DNA so when you open up the
nucleus of the cell the chromosomes come
out in their 46 chromosomes 23 from your
mother and 23 from your father but what
is a chromosome well what it is is a
sleeve of protein wrapped around a
double helix of DNA
and the significance about this is the
telomeres as you can see in this picture
of an X and Y chromosome stained red are
the telomeres at the ends of the
chromosome they're the ends of the DNA
are I say so what is the telomere it's
extensions of DNA after the genes
meaning it's a part of the DNA that
doesn't program anything it's just
extended DNA happiness and gratitude now
that's the big one happiness and
gratitude means you love your life so
much that you want more so unconsciously
you will activate the enzyme to increase
and enhance your life this is also
associated with a positive outlook
because if you have a positive outlook
that means you're looking toward a
future and again feedback says then
we're going to have to activate this
enzyme to have that future and the last
two aspects that enhance the enzyme and
give you long life are very important
and that is again having that self-love
appreciating yourself which means I'm
enjoying and appreciating my life
experience and when you're in love that
of course drives you to stay around even
longer and that will activate the enzyme
and lastly and most importantly is being
in service meaning you have something to
do and what the feedback of the system
is says I can't and now I have to be
here longer I have something to do and
so being in service is one of the most
important things to extend your
telomeres and keep you around and in
conclusion the information about
telomeres and telomerase is very
important because they represent the
equivalent of a fountain of youth in
every cell and between your mind and
your cells the biology of belief reveals
how your Consciousness and your thoughts
can extend your telomeres by activating
telomerase when you appreciate life when
you have gratitude and when you're
looking for love and happiness on the
planet you can extend your life so
interesting you're very powerful to
change your life and make it one of
happiness joy and health for a long long
time once you have identified your
programs
how can you change what do you do with
them and that always comes up because
that's the most important question after
you understand how it works the most
important question is well how do I
change the program and I go this is the
critical part
the conscious mind is creative which
means it can think of anything
the subconscious mind is programmed it's
got habits I go so what I say habits
when you have them it's a habit you do
not want to change a habit which is
important you learn how to walk before
you were too I'm glad you don't change
your habit because you'll forget how to
walk I say nope same program you learned
before too can carry you a hundred years
same program okay habits do not want to
change because if a habit changes then
by definition it's not a habit so the
subconscious mind is habit mind I say
yeah but how do I change I say there's
three ways only
that you can control this
number one how to get the habits in the
first place I say for seven years my
brain was at a low vibration called
Theta which is just below Consciousness
and Theta is the direct hypnosis line to
the subconscious so when you're in Theta
whatever you're experiencing at that
point can be downloaded straight into
the subconscious I said well how do you
get the Theta I say
interesting every day when you're up at
work you've got a high vibration in the
in the brain that's again with the wires
on your head EEG
the high vibration is called beta that's
like School room studying focused
Consciousness when you come home and
relax the vibration goes lower now it
goes into what is called alpha alpha is
calm relaxed Consciousness but when you
get really calm and you're really
relaxed guess what
Alpha shuts off you're sleeping when
you're when Alpha is off you are
sleeping but for the next period of time
right after you fell asleep the brain is
operating in Theta and then it goes to
the lowest vibration deep sleep Delta so
Theta is a period when your mind goes to
sleep it's open for a little while and
Theta is hypnosis
so if you put earphones on
and you play a program at night when you
go to bed every night you go to bed just
before you fall asleep you put the
earphones on you play a program of a
program about health a program how to
make money a program how to be you know
relationships self-help program okay at
night you put the earphones on when you
go to bed
and as soon as you fall asleep you're
not awake anymore Alpha closed you're in
Theta record whatever's coming in
through the earphones is not going into
the conscious mind it's going deeper
into the subconscious it's called
self-hypnosis
you put the pro you put the earphones on
you repeat that because Theta is not a
long period after you fall asleep but if
you repeat it every night you'll get
information into the subconscious so
number one self-hypnosis earphones out
at night play a program that you want to
be true okay and then it'll
automatically happen this is a
demonstration that and it's fun why you
were sleeping you didn't even have to do
any work you just have to go to sleep
and the work would be automatic so when
you wake up after playing this at night
uh the subconscious will have a new
program and one day you wake up and
you're living the new program without
even playing the tapes anymore it's once
it's in it's in okay so number one is
hypnosis self-hypnosis okay
but after age seven the brain is not in
hypnosis uh and now Consciousness is
working I said but you can still learn a
program you could learn a habit and I
say how
practice repetition you want to drive a
car
well I'm not getting in the car until
you practice why because it's the
practice that makes the program strong I
need to empower the people
because they have been invisibly
disempowered without the knowledge that
their life is coming from programs that
they didn't even put in there so sure
and these programs really support what
you want so you play the programs and
all you find is you're not getting what
you want those programs never gave it to
you
you know a famous book uh Kiyosaki wrote
a book called Rich Dad Poor Dad this is
truth here it is simple truth if you
grew up in a rich family you were
programmed how to be rich and how to
have money if you grew up in a poor
family you were programmed to recognize
you don't have any money and you don't
have any power and I say then a rich
person will stay Rich why because 95
percent of their life is coming from the
programs they downloaded from the rich
parents who made all the money
the poor person that's going to stay
poor because 95 of their program comes
from the poverty mentality that their
family experience when they were young
and all of a sudden it says well then
you've got programmed you want to be a
rich kid or a poor kid I said well what
the hell was your program right and the
big one that we're talking about David
is the program of fear because we've all
been programmed with some Vision that
other people have told us about the
afterlife the fear the hell the
damnation oh I don't want to die I go
hey
from what are called near-death
experiences where people have died for a
period of time
almost every one of them says the exact
same thing
it was better out there than it was back
here again and you know because a lot of
them when having this experience or
given a choice do you want to stay here
in the afterlife or you want to go back
and most of them would prefer to have
stayed there but have obligations and
came back right but the point was yeah
you're not this physical body you're the
broadcaster you're the energy but when
you're playing through this body then
you're the experiences of your life at
this point when you're out of body you
are the energy and the energy is forever
people don't realize the power program
here I'll give you one right now cancer
is one of the leading cause of death in
in the world right now and I go but what
I go there's no Gene that causes cancer
what oh their Uncle genes we call these
cancer genes like the breast cancer Gene
I go those are genes associated with
cancer they don't cause the cancer
for you know example so many women live
in fear of the breast cancer Gene
because so many haven't but they live
what's the fear I'm gonna get the cancer
I have the Gene and I said that fear is
a vision which is manifesting into their
reality but then I go you know 50 of the
women that carry the gene never get the
cancer I said what's the point the point
is this possession of the gene didn't
cause cancer
it was a lifestyle that was undermining
your biology that activated expression
of these genes
the gene didn't activate itself so all
of a sudden it says oh my goodness then
the idea of cancer didn't come from the
genes like oh no it came from the
programming programming of disharmony
dysfunction not living in life the fears
that are programmed because our
Consciousness is created in this world
oh that's quantum physics oh yeah that's
epigenetics oh yeah that's absolutely
right that's Placebo I go what do you
mean
I'm sick and the doctor says it's the
greatest newest research pill ever it's
gonna cure you you take the pill you get
better and you go wow yeah that was
great and then you find out the pill was
a sugar pill there's a very important
point
then what the hell heals you
right the conscious belief that you
would be healed manifested healing
and everybody oh yeah Placebo my
thoughts manifested my reality go that's
exactly what it's all about and yet uh
well we are in a discussion of placebo
what people don't discuss which is much
more important to understand is well
positive thinking can heal us negative
thinking is equally powerful in
controlling the character of our lives
so that negative thinking can cause any
disease even death if you just believe
you're going to die you can die just
from the belief of it it's been a very
strange year on this planet chaos is
happening all over the place and we're
looking at this going on what's going on
with our world it seems like it's
turning upside down the interest it
turning upside down now that might be
the bad news for most people but it's
actually for my insight it represents
the good news how could it be the good
news that the world is so filled with
chaos and the answer is simply this is
that human behavior has precipitated the
six mass extinction of Life on this
planet which includes us
five times in a history life was
thriving on this planet in some event
like a comet hitting the Earth upended
the entire ecosystem wiping out of the
ninety percent of life
this is the sixth mass extinction and
the source of this is much closer to
home than a comet because the source of
our Extinction is human behavior we are
undermining the web of life and as a
result there is a collapse of nature
going on all around us if we don't
change we're going to go extinct I'm not
talking A Thousand Years folks I'm
talking decades from now
so what you're seeing is a collapse of a
foundation civilization is changing so
rapidly covet has pushed it super fast
all of things are changing with the
covet the way we work on the world and
we commute on the world things like that
are profoundly different now and we're
moving into a different way of life we
are not going back to the old way of
life we are creating a new version so
when you look at the world falling apart
Don't Be Afraid actually be very joyous
why if it doesn't fall apart Extinction
is right here in a few decades if it
falls apart it gives us an opportunity
to create something better to move from
here to there frequently a mass every
day how come you look so happy and the
answer is I wake up happy and why do I
get this happiness where is it coming
from and the answer is this it's another
day on planet Earth and what's so
exciting about it is it's another day
that I have no idea what's going to
happen but the greatest wishes and
desires for some fun and excitement and
a very joyous life so I start off with
today's going to be a great day and
almost every day it ends up being a
great day doesn't mean everything works
right but the beautiful part about it is
I've really learned not to carry
anything forward that is not really
happy and enjoy Us in my life it reminds
me of a story two Buddhist monks are
walking along and Buddhism are not
allowed to touch women at all and these
two Buddhist months are walking along
they come to a river and not that River
there's a woman dressed in her wedding
Refinery and she's crying and she's
crying because she can't get across the
river wearing these clothes so one of
the monks just picks her up carries her
across drops her off on the other side
then the two monks continue walking
and about an hour and a half down the
road one monk says to the other one how
could you pick up a woman
and the one who picked up the woman
looked at me and said I I dropped her
off an hour and a half ago why are you
still carrying her and the whole idea
about that is the meaning of it is when
events happen in our life it's not
necessary to keep carrying them
especially if they're negative ones you
can just stop right there and go on to
the next thing it's a choice do I want
to be in an environment where I'm not
happy or do I want to be in an
environment where I am happy oh Choice
well obviously but most of us have that
choice but are so caught up in
conventional rules and conventional way
of mannerisms and social structure that
we hold ourselves in places we don't
even want to be and then we sit there in
our mind getting aggravated by the whole
factors I don't even want to be here and
I go well guess what choice
pick a place you want to be go to the
movie go do something else
break the pattern
and when you break the pattern is your
moment of power because when the pattern
is broken there's new choices at that
moment but if you don't break the
pattern you're going to follow a Litany
of up or down depending how you started
off the process the litany down not a
great trip I'll tell you that but hey I
think it's over 20 some years I haven't
been depressed I haven't even been angry
I get upset by some things of course but
it doesn't mean I hold them I drop that
person off on the other side of the
river and stop carrying it
and this is the choice it really is a
choice you have to think about it
because it's a conscious Awakening at a
moment that gives you a choice that
wakes up and goes do I want to do this
and that's that moment of choice you
take that moment of choice and then you
say I'm moving into where I want to go
you make a habit out of this because you
repeat this and then guess what you
don't even have to think about it
anymore because the subconscious program
will always redirect you to the place
you want to be and the whole other world
that we used to experience that used to
irritate us and aggravate us and all
that anxiety stuff
just doesn't exist and it doesn't mean
everything's going right but the whole
beautiful part about it is well if it
doesn't go right okay stop now let's go
do something else
because it's the idea it didn't go right
and then why didn't go right and who
didn't make it right and where is it
going to go now and blah blah blah and
what are you doing you're digging a hole
and it's not going up it's going down
and the whole idea is choice
the most important part of choice is you
have to stop long enough not get caught
up in in the in the program and play out
the program there's a moment while
you're playing the program maybe you can
separate and look at yourself and say
why am I doing this because that is the
moment of power that is the moment where
you can say I have a choice I can do
something totally different than to Stew
in this stuff
and then you are a powerful person how
effective is your conscious mind at
overriding the subconscious I say it
works five percent of the time with a
miniature computer and I go wow that's
your problem
I go the only way you can override the
program is not play the program that's
when we said stay Mindful and then we
then say well that's going to be
difficult because we have to think
so there's only one way out
no no don't keep it a secret tell
everybody
there's only one way out
reprogram the subconscious mind
and I go significance if you would put
wishes and desire programs into the
subconscious mind
that means that that program would be
operating 95 percent of the Day meaning
whether your conscious mind is in
control saying these are my wishes and
desires or the conscious minds thinking
then the subconscious mind comes in and
said these are my wishes and desires
then guess what then 100 of your life
your living wishes and desires
and therefore all of a sudden then the
the the work has to come back to each of
us as individuals each of us got
programmed each of us is manifesting
that program we give up our power in
many of the programs the fine example is
you were sick as a kid and just like
your parents and any other family
members when you were sick you went to
the doctor
I go that's a habit I said what does it
mean it says you learned this in the
first seven years the program it says
when you're sick you give up this power
and you go to that doctor and you accept
the doctor as the power of over you
because when it came to health it's like
no no you don't do it the doctor doesn't
that's the program I say so what's the
point you have given up power over the
control of your life and have given it
to the truths quote unquote offered by
the doctor I go significance I go
the doctor misreads your diagnosis and
then tells you oh I'm sorry you only
have three months left to live
I'm gonna go significance
95 of the day the program says the
doctor is the you know
the correct one the true what do I know
the doctor knows what do I know so 95 of
the day then your belief system is going
to do what take the words of the doctor
and manifest them as truth I go what's
that mean well you're going to die in
about three months I go from what I go
hey that was a misdiagnosis you're still
gonna die because your belief system
will manifest an illness that will
terminate the cancer for example is not
due to any genes there's no Gene that
causes cancer
the genes are correlated with cancer and
I go what causes cancer I say disharmony
and repressed anger is one of the big
ones I go so then I say the genes didn't
cost I say no
so I said then what caused it I say my
Consciousness I say what repressed anger
you know and I go so what I say We'll
change Consciousness and guess what
you can go into remission
the cancer will go away as soon as you
change the Consciousness and all of a
sudden it's like I thought I was a
victim of the jeans I said that's a
program
and that is totally incorrect
because as quantum physics says
Consciousness is creating our life
experiences and as the new biology which
I'm familiar with called epigenetics is
how Consciousness controls the genetics
and all of a sudden I say oh well then
biology and quantum physics now share
the same story yeah you're creating this
and the idea is that if you look at the
creation you're not happy with it don't
go out and blame the creation
because you never saw that you were
participating in a way invisible to you
that led to this expression
if you want to change it you have to
change you
and then the environment will change the
fear
which is human specific
is the fear of mortality
there's no other organism that knows
it's going to die
and I say that fear
is what then we gave up our power to
have somebody assuage that fear it's
like oh it's not so bad or whatever you
know we we bought what religion why did
we buy religion well I want to tell you
about what happens after you die the big
mystery and I say oh then all of a
sudden guess what they made the program
for my life I go who the hell are you to
make a program for my life well I bought
it because I was in fear and fear means
I have no power and when I have no power
I'm going to seek someone who says they
have the power and then I'm going to
accommodate what they do and so people
join in a religion because they have the
fear of the afterlife well I'm going to
tell you the beautiful part about my
research was I didn't believe in
spirituality okay I had no to me
afterlife was home I'm chemicals and
when I die I go back into chemistry you
know that's what it is
but when I understood this said oh my
God
I'm an immortal entity I'm a spiritual
field quantum mechanics a field
and all of a sudden I started to realize
oh my goodness I I I have no fear why
I'm not gonna die I'm not even in here
so how the hell am I going to die and
once that fear
was gone my life was radically different
I tell you why
because we all live with that biological
imperative that says I'm afraid to die
and I said but what if you're not afraid
to die what if you don't see death as an
end what if you see it's just a
transition into another way and all of a
sudden I say what the consequence of
that is no fear I said then what does
that mean I said then I'm more powerful
because it was the fear that took away
my power and if I don't have fear then
you can't scare me and I don't I'm not
scared and I don't care about your rules
about afterlife because I have my own
understanding now you don't have to try
and tell me about afterlife I know what
I am I'm a spirit I'm an energy field
the immune system protects you from a
threat on the inside yeah but if the
tiger's chasing you who cares about the
threat on the inside I go I've got a
bacterial infection and a saber-toothed
tiger Chase I mean where should I put my
energy in the hell with the infection
the tiger catches you that infection's
not a problem anymore so very important
fact profoundly everyone listen
stress hormones specifically shut down
the immune system because the taking
care of the inside is not as important
as taking care of the whole thing
running away uh in fact stress hormones
are so good at this
that when doctors want to transplant an
organ from person a into person B the
recipient of that organ is given stress
hormones before the operation because it
reduces the function of the immune
system which would be rejecting The
graft and so you don't want the immune
system to reject a graph so you give
them stress hormones which what shuts
down the immune system I go well guess
what in today's world just watch the
news for a moment and all of a sudden
your immune system is going
yeah so that's number two so number one
stress hormone shut down growth because
feeding the viscera for its function not
worth the uh of running away I need to
get the blood into the arms and legs uh
again to conserve energy because look
the immune system uses a lot of energy
if you've ever been sick sometimes you
don't have the energy to get out of bed
so it's like well when it's operating it
could drain you of energy yeah but if
you're being chased by a saber tooth
tiger
the hell with the immune system uh and
so you shut that down so those are two
insults to the system in other words if
I'm not under stress I'm nourishing my
body and I'm encouraging my immune
system I'm staying healthy but the
moment I'm under stress
both of those things shut down and I'm
ready to to fight or flight uh and then
I said well there's a third one I call
that adding insult to injury and the
answer about what that means is this the
brain has the forebrain where conscious
thinking is conscious thinking and the
Haim brain which is uh like habit and
reflex Behavior conscious thinking is
slow
I mean imagine your car is going out of
control and spinning and I say stay in
the conscious mind it's like oh
I said yeah but the moment the car
starts to go out of control the stress
hormones go in remember I told you they
squeezed the blood vessels in the gut
they squeezed the blood vessels in the
forebrain I say why because it pushes
the blood
to the hindbrain which is a million
times more powerful than the forebrain
is a machine processor I go so why is a
relent I go because the moment the car
is going out of control is oh wow you're
turning the wheel hitting the pedals
you're doing everything Beyond fast so
fast okay yes so when you're in a
stressful situation thinking is slow
and therefore the system doesn't want
you to be slow it needs you to go boom
react reflect right away so the blood
vessels from the same chemistry
squeezing the blood vessels down the gut
squeeze the blood vessels here push it
to the hindbrain we become less
intelligent when we're under stress
because now we're reactive and it gets
to a point that sometimes they're so
afraid that you take care of me and then
we give up we give up control to the guy
with the bigger stick yes you take care
of me well that means we're a victim
victim means we're powerless I go when
stress hormones are in the system the
only Power you have is to run and I go
and relevance about that is very is very
simple and that is that
it was only designed with saber-toothed
tigers of mine I go why is that real
they say well the Sabertooth tiger is
chasing I go yeah and I'm running like
crazy I got blood in my arms and legs I
got all the energy and I say yeah but if
you escape that tiger in a few minutes
of running
then there's no more threat
and then all of a sudden the stress
hormones are gone and then you're back
into growth and everything else
but today stress is 24 7 365 a human
body was never designed to be
maintaining a stress situation because
it suppresses the Vitality of the system
and in today's world with the idea of
covid everyone's afraid I go and guess
what the one thing you wanted was your
immune system to work and the one thing
that's not working because you're afraid
is the immune system I go the more fear
people have the sicker they become yes
and this is a wake-up call that says man
we have to stop listening to that fear
of drum they keep beating the drum every
or everybody's gonna die I don't know
I'm just getting to die
there are people who are indeed
vulnerable because they're already
stressed immune system people that live
in stress are already open to a problem
uh older people whose immune system is
are not working up to the fullest
capability they're under threat because
their immune system is already
compromised and then there's the people
with what are called comorbidities what
are they I say these are stressors on
the system that are chronic overweight
is one of the biggest ones in the
serious cases of covid 78 of those
serious patients were overweight why
overweight is a challenge to the system
and you're already challenging your
immune system before the damn virus
showed up so that's a big problem uh
Diabetes Type 2 meaning that's a stress
World diabetes is a stressor that's in
the system the more stressors that you
have going
the less effective your immune system is
so it turns out here's a number
unfortunately Americans
UH 60 of Americans have at least one
comorbidity they're slightly compromised
okay but forty percent and this is where
the issue comes from have two or more
simultaneous comorbidities these are
people that are ripe for infection why
their immune systems are already
compromised before the damn virus showed
up so it's like well then I'm am I
afraid of coven I said well if you're a
healthy person no if you're you know if
you're a compromised person then you
should be taking care of yourself I
don't have to take care of myself you
have to take care of yourself because
you're the one that's open and yet we
want everybody to put on the mask and
everybody to get the vaccines I go
that that
stuff I was going to say a bad word that
stuff
is not valid I go to me it's not Val I
say
the country of Gibraltar 100
of that population has been vaccinated
and guess what Delta went through there
like a plague man and I say yeah but
they were all vaccinated I go yeah
because the vaccine doesn't work I go
well yeah but now while we're Chronicle
no the vaccine doesn't work and they say
well get your booster shot I said get
the booster shot didn't even work the
damn first time it takes a second time
it doesn't work and so the real issue is
this
we have to take care of our health
uh and not wait for other people to
protect me from them if I'm a vulnerable
person it's my responsibility to take
care of my health mind controls not just
what genes are being activated but mine
can alter the blueprint I can make 3 000
different proteins from the same
blueprint just based on how I see the
world so all of a sudden it says wow we
are very powerful We're The Architects
and we can create help we can also
create disease because we're the creator
of it okay so now comes the the big part
and that is this
to me the most valid science on this
planet is quantum physics quantum
physics I say that because uh back in
1927 when it was theoretical they came
up with a whole bunch of things you know
Albert Einstein Max Planck Heisenberg
that came up with a theory of how
everything worked well it's nearly a
hundred years and guess what almost all
of their theories are totally accurate
so we have a deep deep understanding of
quantum physics Consciousness is
creating our life experience principle
number one it was back in 1927 Max
Planck founder one of the founders said
the mind is the Matrix of all matter
that's where the movie The Matrix comes
from do you see value in going backwards
in other words in Psychotherapy or in
going back to the past no
why wouldn't I why didn't I say value in
that I said because when you go back and
Replay that problem
you've exercised that problem again you
have pushed the buttons that created the
problem in the first place that's why
they have so many boxes of tissues in
the in the psych office because you're
going to cry your eyes out why because
you're going to be replaying the trauma
of what caused the problem and this is
the cool part
it no longer exists it's not there
anymore except for you carrying it with
you there's a point where I say well
then why should I go back and repeat
this because it's just going to cause a
replay of the same program which
reinforces that program I go I don't
care about the past I care about here I
am today I want to go this way what do I
want today I don't care about what
happened back there not that I should
forget about it because I don't want to
replay it again but it doesn't control
me anymore because I say replaying that
is just the you know putting a in the
old days they had records you guys don't
know about but they had knee record and
if you keep quiet the needle gets deeper
in the group like we don't want to play
it again so it's irrelevant to go back I
like it there's a story of a two
Buddhist monks and monks are not the the
male monks are not allowed to touch
women and these two monks are walking
along the path and they come to a river
and there's a woman and all dressed up
in her wedding finery and she's crying
and crying and it's what's wrong she
says well I can't get across the water
and you know I'll ruin my clothes and so
one monk just picture up
walks across drops her on the other side
and then the two monks walk down the
street about half hour 45 minutes later
the one that didn't pick her up turns to
him he said you picked up a woman back
there
and then the other monk says I put her
down 45 minutes ago you're still
carrying her
and if you get the story the story is
this it was over
the history is over do I want to repeat
it no so there's a way of seeing what it
was but I don't have to repeat it
because I have to say what is it I want
not what is it I don't want a lot of
people I don't want this I go yeah but
what is it you want
people have more problems answering what
it is they want than saying what they
don't want and the important part about
this is you can only move into the
future that you want by acknowledging
what you want not saying I don't want
that anymore I said well that didn't
that didn't give you your future uh and
and so yes there are ways to reprogram
the subconscious uh and when you do your
life will change in permanently as you
understand the terms quantum physics and
quantum mechanics or Newtonian physics
or Newtonian mechanics what you see is
that physics and mechanics are synonyms
so physics really means the mechanisms
by which the universe operates and the
new physics quantum physics was
something that I really wasn't into nor
were any of my colleagues in the medical
school we were all trained in Newtonian
physics and the difference between the
two is very profound Newtonian physics
says the world that we live in the
universe we live in is a machine made
out of mechanical parts if you want to
understand how it works take it apart
study the pieces change the pieces
change the operation That's the basis of
medicine we look at a human body it's a
machine made out of physical parts when
it's not working right change the parts
by buying chemicals and drugs and that's
the way that conventional medicine
operates when I started to read the
quantum physics I realized oh my
goodness the the whole foundation of the
universe is not based on a mechanical
physical Universe it's based on the
invisible energy called the field so
let's say if I hold a magnet right here
in front of you and you can see the
magnet but what you can see is the
invisible magnetic field and so what it
says is well we are physical things in
our world like physical bodies we're
immersed in fields electro magnetic
fields magnetic fields itself all kinds
of fields like telephone cell phone
Fields television Fields radio Fields
whole ranges
what is the difference between the
Newtonian physics and the quantum
physics is this Newtonian physics focus
on the particles quantum physics says
you want to understand why the particles
take this shape then you have to
understand the field it's the field that
controls biology it's the invisible
forces there's a great quote by Albert
Einstein and it's simple it goes the
field is the sole governing agency of
the particle in other words in the world
of invisible things fields and particles
matter
it's the field that gives shape to the
matter and this is the basis of quantum
physics this becomes relevant it says
okay here's the physical particles of my
body why are they in a healthy state or
why could they be in a sick State that's
the physical expression and the answer
is well to understand that don't look at
the body you have to understand the
invisible forces in the field
it's fun because if you think about when
when of course when you were young at
some point you must have had like iron
filings and sprinkled it around a magnet
and all of a sudden you saw the iron
filings form that pattern of the
magnetic field
well quantum physics would look at this
pattern and try to explain how come all
the iron filings fell in this pattern
without recognizing that the field
exists in other words can you explain
why the iron filings have this shape if
you don't recognize a magnetic field the
answer is absolutely not what's the
nature of it the body and its cells are
like iron filings medicine is trying to
understand the nature of the body by
looking at the iron filings and quantum
physics says if you don't understand
that invisible field you can't ever
understand what's happening in the body
it's time for us to wake up and
recognize that there's a program being
played out here we're in a darwinian
program because everyone accepts that as
oh that's the science even though
darwinian theory is wrong because this
revolution isn't on competition
evolution is cooperation that's the new
insight that changes the game of
struggle into harmony when we start to
recognize we all have been programmed
with a belief that uh if you're not out
there fighting somebody's going walk all
over you and you lose so you better go
out there and and struggle and win and
fight and all that and I Go Again a
garden is not a Battleground it's the
height of cooperation and Harmony and
what we have to do is let go and the
idea is the more you invest in the
existing program the more Consciousness
you feed that existing program The More
You broadcast the pattern of that
existing program and the only way out is
stop
does that mean I don't read the news
well actually I don't read it I just
read the damn headlines and that's
enough for me to go okay I don't I don't
want to be there I live in a different
world no I'm in the same world as you
know but I live in a different world why
well sometimes we have to recognize
maybe it's time to take your power back
maybe it's time to take your job back
and do something that is more in harmony
with your life I mean I was a tenured
professor in a medical school but when I
realized I I was teaching incorrect
information at Gene's control life which
is totally false uh I I said no I I
can't tell you this anymore
and uh and the Beautiful part about it
is guess what I'm living this most
wonderful life and I go how did I do
that I said I had to let go of the
programs that I knew I was engaged in
that didn't offer Vitality Life Energy
love if they didn't offer then get the
hell off of it because it sucks your
energy energy is life I talk about
what's called the energy checkbook and I
go what's that I go you have a bank
account that's the money in there is
your life I go yeah it is I go you just
don't write checks for nothing hey oh
Lynn what a beautiful blue sweater you
have here let me give you twenty dollars
that was really nice you know you don't
do something like that and I say we have
been giving away our energy
so much with no return coming back I go
what do you mean I said well you you get
into some like a political argument uh
between people and they go oh heated
oven
and they use all this energy and I said
and after the argument what changed
nothing
I said then what the heck energy is life
you just gave away your energy you're
losing life and that's when all of a
sudden I realized
invest your energy into things that
either enhance your Vitality or the
Vitality of the world in which we're
living because those are places to Build
a Better World to invest your energy in
the negative things and all that kind of
stuff like that you're building a bad
world with that and you're using your
own energy your life gets shortened and
so the reality is consciousness is real
it's a currency and if you use it and
spend it appropriately you can have a
much better life negative beliefs are
equally powerful in controlling your
health as are positive beliefs except in
the opposite direction a positive belief
can heal you from any disease
a negative belief can kill you
by creating any disease a belief can
create the disease as much as belief can
create the healing and I guess the
significance of this is profound because
nobody talks about the negative belief
and I go negative beliefs are powerful
this cause no sibo as you mentioned and
as I said they can cause any disease and
they can kill you just because you
believe you're going to die you can die
just from the belief it's as much as you
are dying of a cancer you change your
belief and you can then heal the cancer
I go how I love this because a friend of
mine her name is Anita morjani and she
wrote a book called dying to be me she
had four years of cancer and the final
days of her life
in the final week she was so emaciated
that the cancer lumps were sticking out
of her skin because she lost so much
body weight and the cancer notes are
sticking out
she's on a machine for life support
she goes into a coma in her oncologist
who's been working with cancer patients
for years says oh this is the final
stage of a person before they die
so get in touch with all the family
members and say uh Anita is dying she's
in a coma this is a sign that's the end
of her life
and she has an out-of-body experience a
Consciousness change that the issues
that were related to her life had to do
with a lot of
um the fact that uh she was so feeling
guilty of upsetting her family she came
from an Indian family with pre-arranged
marriages and she pulled out of a
pre-arranged marriage about three days
before the wedding which made her family
look like you know local people it's
like you broke a pre-arranged marriage
that's like against the rules and
everything that irritated her father who
she was she had a lot of love but then
that irritated her father and then she
felt she's now alienated from that love
that's what precipitated the cancer
her out-of-body experience on the last
day of her life according to her
oncologist uh she had an auto body
experience of communicating with her
dead father who said no you know what
happened on that what happened on Earth
stays on earth when you transcend you're
not there anymore and everything's
wonderful and we love you and all that
she comes out of the coma
and the first thing she says I want to
eat something you know she was like give
me some ice cream and she was like what
you know
within a day she was off the machines
within two within a week to two weeks
there was no visible cancer anymore and
in fact the doctors were saying it's in
there somewhere and she kept saying no
there's no more cancer
and they kept looking after a couple
more weeks of looking they said no she
doesn't have any sign of cancer she was
on her last day of life with cancer
and a belief change that she realized
her father is not angry with her she
didn't alienate the love of her family
and and that thought
when she woke up out of the coma was the
placebo in a sense of the healing
thought that healed her from her last
day of life so people with cancer and
they're all struggling I go even to the
very last day the moment you change that
Consciousness is the moment you can have
the cancer go into remission and
disappear killing the cancer cells is
like oh I'm going to get those evil
cells and I said the cells were just
following the instructions that came
from your Consciousness you don't want
evil cells then change the evil thoughts
coming from your Consciousness the
cancer disappears so it's a power
that we have it's a power of our
creativity which we don't believe in and
I go okay
quantum physics is the most valid
truthful science in the sense that the
theoretical understanding of quantum
physics matches every experiment that
has been understood about it I go so I
go well let me tell you the first
principle of quantum physics
that principle is
Consciousness is creating our life
experiences
you want to change your life experiences
don't change the world
change the Consciousness the world will
change behind that the subconscious mind
is yours not shared by anybody else so
it's not a common mind for for
civilization it's what you've downloaded
what you learned and how you're you know
playing in your life your conscious mind
though that's the one that is coming
from the field uh where everyone else is
involved and so Consciousness is what
connects us all subconscious is your
life experiences it's used for this
lifetime uh and something as the new
science revealed to me which I didn't
really know for most of my life is that
uh We Are Spiritual entities I I was
teaching genes you know and now I start
to recognize from the physics that we
Are Spiritual entities uh and that uh
the body is like a television set my
spirit is the broadcast where when the
television
foreign's dead but is the broadcast
still there and the answer of course
it's still there and I said yes this is
the same thing with the human we are not
in this body we are receiving a
broadcast of field in terms of the
science of quantum physics there's a
field that's playing through us and I go
so if your body dies the field didn't
die it's still there it's like that blew
my mind because I said oh my God you
can't die you're not even in it here and
then the The Joy about that was you also
come back again when another embryo has
the same set of what are called
self-receptors that are reading that
field for you each of us has our own set
of these self-receptors These are
proteins no two people have the same
sense so each of us is receiving a
different energy broadcast then let's
just turn it back for a second to the
subconscious mind the subconscious mind
is learned in this lifetime from the
experiences we have in this lifetime but
when you pass on and go back to the
field subconscious is gone and when you
come back again guess what fresh
subconscious and you start all over
again so the subconscious is used now
for this life the conscious is always
here it's involved whether you're in
this body or not in this body and that
is the Perpetual person that you really
are I want peace on the earth and all
the rest of fighting all over the place
that means nothing
but if I get enough people
to say we want peace on Earth and we get
to that number and as Lynn said it
didn't start with a massive number
started with a small number but that
number grew why Buckminster Fuller
singer says Build a Better World people
will come from that world to visit your
world and what Lynn is showing we can
build a better world and why is it
increasing a number of people because
people are saying I want what Linz has
it always reminds me of the movie
the restaurant and another woman at a
table watching her goes I want what she
has well this is what Lynn and Brian
offer they have something to say they
have something I want what she has why
because it's empowering why
it changes your Consciousness your
Consciousness is creating
if the creation doesn't look good you
don't change the world you change the
Consciousness the world then changes
because of your creativity and that's
why
um Lynn's work to me is so important to
get people to wake up and say miracles
happen when you get enough tuning Forks
together and how many well apparently
eight tuning Forks is good to change
when you think about someone who's an
artist and they're creating a musician a
chef a chef a chef or or in love like
you're in the flow right so you're just
because you're you're whatever you're
thinking yeah you're not thinking you're
doing and it doesn't mean there's not
participation it just means that you're
not thinking of the future you're kind
of just what the time and space sort of
change like you lose track of time yeah
that kind of stuff yeah not thinking
means not diverting to the subconscious
meaning you stay in conscious creativity
yeah how does creativity his wishes and
desires so a chef uh is so involved with
the cooking and paying attention to all
the details they're not thinking and I
say well what does that mean they're not
coming from program they're coming from
creativity okay the artist the chef uh
the race car driver yeah not thinking
man uh you know we're in it we're going
I had a monk tell me I should write a
book called the speed feet of
Consciousness well that that's it and
the subconscious is much faster than the
conscious and that's why in times of
Emergency the conscience is too slow to
help us and that's why we jump to it but
then the problem is whatever Behavior
you're going to express while you're in
that subconscious was a program that you
had a positive or negative well up to 60
percent of the programs that you
downloaded are not positive they're
disempowering programs and in today's
world we're told don't go by the
feelings if I did I would have probably
been better off at this moment so when
we recognize we have to make a decision
we can do it in two fundamental ways
first do an assessment an analysis of
step by step what does this decision
mean and why should I choose it but when
you get to the end before you absolutely
take that information and make a
decision based on that ask your heart
and the reason why is this the heart
doesn't care about the individual steps
in the decision the heart only looks at
the conclusion either you get more
energy from this decision a good vibe a
feeling that this is right or the heart
will give you a feeling of bad vibes
less energy a feeling that maybe this
isn't the right answer so the
significance is really profound because
the heart just reads energy and higher
energy is more life less energy is less
life so in making a decision yes it's
acceptable to do the analysis but before
you come to that final decision please
check in with your heart feel the
feelings if the feelings are good that
means go toward that direction but if
you feel questioned about it you feel
weaker about it doesn't just feel right
the heart is telling you right off that
that energy is not good for you and you
should use some other decision oh wow
that's so wonderful what a wonderful way
to make a decision based on these
feelings and they can help us find the
direction that we need to go in and lead
us to a better life
[Music]
uh oh
I guess that's not really working for me
at this moment
whoops
oh well
computer and simulation
[Music]
Scotty how many times have I told you
not to leave me off and see you know I
can't swim
meet me at the bridge you have some
explaining to do in the year 2018
astronaut Dr Bruce Lipton set out on a
voyage to save Humanity upon the
assumption that Earth was dying and
humankind needed a new home however just
prior to launch new studies emerge from
Chernobyl the once devastated landscape
has regrown Nature has returned
unfortunately something went terribly
wrong and Dr Bruce Lipton was sent into
outer space many problems occurred and
Dr Bruce Lipton became lost
lost in the vastness of space
this is his journey
after 20 long years being Lost in Space
Bruce Lipton is finally coming home
oh wow what a welcoming sight look at
that beautiful blue green gem floating
in the darkness of space I'm going home
it's gonna be great now if I could just
get this ready for re-entry Mission
Control Mission Control astronaut Bruce
Lipton coming back home from the outer
limits with our beautiful rocket ship
please come in
I guess
maybe they're they're just busy right
now but well I've got such a great story
to tell them when I get back
[Music]
oh fresh air man being in that little
can for 20 years out there this oh it's
so wonderful oh it's beautiful and it is
beautiful here God just think about how
much time I spent out there in open
space looking for another place for us
to live another planet and I come back
here and look at this it is so beautiful
I didn't ever have to leave
gosh when I left here this whole place
seemed to be falling down man the
environment was collapsing all around us
the rainforests were being cut down
people were destroying the air the water
the land look at it now wow these people
have really created something new ah
created something new well that's not an
accident that creation is a
participation at that time when I left
and the world looked like it was on its
last stages something happened they
people must have learned how to change
the world but in order to do that they
first really had to learn how to change
themselves you really have to understand
at some level if we're going to create a
garden like this and somewhere along the
line we have to create their own garden
in our own Consciousness first and
that's where we start to come from
reality humans have imagination they can
imagine a garden but then humans have
the ability to manifest recognize this
you have 50 trillion citizen cells
living under your skin a community that
lives in harmony if we really want to
understand how to live in harm and evil
look within that's where the answers are
how can 50 trillion cells provide for a
happy healthy human being because they
understood the nature of community
fractal universe and fractal Universe
simply means this a structure geometry
of the universe that represents As Above
So Below meaning if you understand the
structure at any level you can
understand it at any other level and so
if we really want to understand how to
create this beautiful planet then we
have to recognize this how do the cells
do it in our body because 50 trillion of
them came together in a community and
learned to live in harmony and provide
for their environment but then if we
understand how the cells did it then we
can understand how the people can do it
because we have to use the same
principles it's fractal to change the
planet and make it the garden that it
has become right now but then of course
you can't get there if you don't know
where you're going so before we even
embark on the trail we must first
visualize in our Consciousness what is
it we're seeking what are we trying to
manifest where are we going and once we
get that picture in our mind then we can
become the artist and manifest that
picture in the real world situation and
just by the looks of this Garden we
obviously must have learned our lesson
and of course where are these people
where are these people
hello hello hello
you Maniacs you finally did it you blew
it up damn you are how
well the other day I was going through
my toy box and guess what I found
something I'm saying for a long long
time my wonderful wonderful
Etch-a-Sketch now many of you may have
had this when you were young as well but
I really loved it you know why it gave
you an opportunity to make a drawing on
this screen by turning these Styles down
here and then after you complete the
drawing you can then Shake It Up and the
drawing will disappear and you can make
another drawing so it's like a reusable
pen and paper just shake it and make a
new one so here let's take a look at how
you do it and I'll try it it's been a
long time since I've done it but uh let
me work on it here's how it works
so well you can see I'm a little out of
practice on it but here's the beautiful
part here's a drawing that I just made
and I created this image and then
manifested it on the screen of the Etch
A Sketch so what's really interesting is
what I can do is now shake up this
screen and erase the image and then I
can create another one perhaps this one
is going to be a little better than the
last one let's see what I can do this
time
well what a great picture but what we
can do is just shake it up
oh what the hell is going on behind me
what what oh my God the world is
collapsing
so why is this relevant because there's
a lot we can learn about Evolution
through a nature sketch wow what we're
experiencing right now is a process
called Evolution well it's not the
evolution we learned in school the
Darwin version that's the kind of
evolution it says evolution is gradual
changes over billions of years
imperceptible but over a long time you
see an outcome that's different in
contrast to the old version of evolution
the gradualism version there's a new
understanding of Illusion called
punctuated equilibrium uh this is a
theory that was devised by Stephen J
Gould and Niles Eldridge and what do
they recognize is that when looking for
fossils there were different layers
where fossils of animals that no longer
exist and then there's like a space and
then there's another layer with fossils
of animals that no longer exist and then
another space and they said well there's
something going on there's a development
a punctuation another development and a
punctuation the punctuations are natural
events that destroyed the nature of the
Web of Life at that time and in fact the
last one of these mass extinctions is
attributed to a giant Comet that hit
near the Yucatan Peninsula and upended
the web of life and at that last
Extinction 66 million years ago remember
before the comet hit the planet was
filled with lush tropical force and
dinosaurs
after the comet hit
they don't exist anymore the strata that
we see in the fossils is really the same
stories we see in the amateur sketch the
stratum means that something happened
there was a picture then the picture
changed and a new picture formed on the
next strata and then that picture
changed the understanding about the
nature of the Etch A Sketch and what's
actually going on in our world right now
are really the same story we've created
an image it's not sustainable and and
the answer sketch is shaking but the
planet is shaking the planet is telling
us that Civilization you have created is
no longer sustainable and it's time for
us to create a more thrivable situation
for us to move into the future there's
an old saying there's no such thing as a
news story well in fact interesting
point we can go back thousand years and
start to recognize that the Buddhists
were telling us the same story in a
different fashion they were making what
are called sand mandalas and these are
very ornate Creations from different
Sands instead of paint different sand
creating a struck structure and then
making this most beautiful structure and
they also recognize just like the
universe says things don't always stay
the same so after they create this most
beautiful expression then they take all
the sand and scoop it all together and
make a big pile and start all over again
for another image just as in the story
with the mandala and the same story of
the atro sketch and the same story that
we're experiencing on this planet right
now there's a very important point that
says that we can move into the future
but take with us what we learned from
the past to build a better future to
thrive into that future and this is
where we are right now shaking it up so
that Civilization come together in a new
version with love Harmony and peace
while we're in this state of chaos it's
a very important point about you the
Observer of what wife just been talking
about I go why is this important because
you represent cultural creatives you are
the people that are looking for answers
to how to get into the future from the
destruction we're facing right now and
the answers are not in a box so just by
even watching what we're talking about
right here is the idea to give you the
Insight of how powerful you are in
creating the new future your
participation is involved in this
Evolution this is not a passive event
you sit at home and wait for evolution
this is where we go out and manifest
Evolution and just like in the story The
Answer sketch you can put your hands on
the dial and start to create a new image
as well and so collectively when we all
work together the new image is a new
civilization one that can take us from
today into a future this is the moment
of manifesting a new civilization not
just for the people but for mother
nature herself and this is our
opportunity to participate in conscious
evolution if we understand what's going
on we can flow with nature instead of
resisting it yes and flow out of the
chaos which is not random but taking us
to the new world right and therefore uh
if we can learn how to change our
behavior and become more in harmony with
the world which is what nature is
calling on us to do then we can create a
sustainable thrivable situation right
now uh it's not sustainable the system
is crashing because we cannot maintain
the way we have lived so that means we
have to change the way we live and I go
yeah but that's culture and that's
behavior and so it says you have to
change behavioral then we have to let go
of a behavior to create a better
behavior and well most people have to
hit their heads against the wall and go
through all this process again what
we've been talking about is well can I
make it easier and the answer is of
course you can make it easier we can do
psychic balance and change behaviors in
minutes and so we don't have to be part
of the struggle in the chaos we could
already be at the new end wait for the
other people to come out of the chaos
and join us because you made it this far
in a video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome to get some incredible Joe
dispenza motivation check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there taking time to be in the
presence of yourself and ask yourself
important questions like are you happy
who am I and instead of getting up and
getting on your cell phone and getting
distracted sit with your triple filtered
water